Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the little plots of those reckless and guilty aristocrats have led. They have abused the weakness of the king to advise him to undertake so pernicious a deed. For their own selfish interests and the vengeance of their pride, they have exposed the patrie to the horrors of the most murderous civil war. The king, whom they say they love, to the loss of his crown, and all his family to the most frightful consequences. They have been undone as they always will be, and their criminal efforts will come down on their heads. I won't complain of that. They deserve their fate. But the king, what humiliation. previous episode, he is the aristocratic deputy of the National Assembly. And that is a letter that he wrote to his wife describing one of the most dramatic episodes in European history,
感谢您收听《历史的余味》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入。那些鲁莽而有罪的贵族所策划的阴谋已经导致了这一切。他们利用国王的软弱，劝说他做出如此有害的举动。为了他们自私的利益和那虚荣的复仇，他们将祖国置于最血腥的内战恐怖之中。他们声称所爱的国王，因他们而失去了王冠，他的整个家庭也因此陷入了最可怕的境地。他们终将自食其果，他们的罪恶行径必将报应在自己头上。我不会抱怨这一点。他们罪有应得。但国王，那是何等的屈辱。上一集，他是国民议会的贵族代表。那是一封他写给妻子的信，描述了欧洲历史上最戏剧性的事件之一，
namely the attempt by Louis XVI and Marie Antoinette with their children to escape Paris in disguise in June 1791, leave Paris behind. I mean, we'll be discussing what Louis actually hoped he would achieve if the attempt had been successful, but it wasn't Dominic. And yet another turning point in the transformation of France from the greatest monarchy in Europe to a republic. It's a truly extraordinary story, this, Tom. So there are moments in the French Revolution that feel like the purest melodrama on. And this is absolutely one of them. And it's a thriller, actually. It's a really thrilling story. And the climax, the way it unfolds, changes the course of French history, arguably European
即1791年6月，路易十六和玛丽·安托瓦内特带着孩子乔装逃离巴黎，离开巴黎。我的意思是，我们将讨论如果这次尝试成功，路易实际上希望实现什么，但多米尼克，它并没有成功。这是法国从欧洲最伟大的君主制国家转变为共和国的又一个转折点。汤姆，这真是一个非凡的故事。法国大革命中确实有一些时刻感觉就像最纯粹的通俗剧。这绝对是其中之一。而且它实际上是一部惊悚片。这是一个非常惊心动魄的故事。它的高潮，它的展开方式，改变了法国历史的进程，甚至可以说是欧洲
history. This gamble that goes, spoiler alert, horribly, horribly wrong. And I love it because it goes with the grain of so much of what we know already about some of the main players. So Louis, Marie Antoinette, some of their hangers-on who we've been hearing about throughout the series, and they appear yet again. So it's a very dramatic story. But of course, as you say, I mean, really its significance is the impact it will have on the whole course of the revolution and therefore of French history. Yeah, definitely. So let's remind ourselves where we got to last time. So last time, actually, Tom, you took us through an equally extraordinary episode, the Women's March on Versailles in October 1789.
历史的进程。这场赌博——剧透预警——错得离谱。我喜欢它，因为它符合我们已经了解到的关于一些主要参与者的许多情况。所以路易、玛丽·安托瓦内特，以及我们在整个系列中一直听到的他们的一些追随者，他们再次出现了。所以这是一个非常戏剧性的故事。但当然，正如你所说，它的意义在于它将对整个革命进程以及法国历史产生的影响。是的，绝对是。那么让我们回顾一下上次我们讲到了哪里。上次，汤姆，你带我们经历了一个同样非凡的事件，即1789年10月的凡尔赛妇女大游行。
And we ended with the royal family being brought back in that, an incredibly humiliating moment there, actually. They're brought back in this great procession by the fishwives and by the National Guard, with the National Assembly eventually trailing behind them to Paris, and they're installed in the Tuileries Palace. So that was last time. And now let's move on 12 months to the end of 1790 and look at where the revolution has got to. The revolution proper, I suppose you could call it, has been going for more than a year. It's more than a year after the fall of the Bastille, the Estates General becoming the National Assembly, and basically the deputies seizing sovereignty, seizing power from the king. And the focus of the story now is no longer in Versailles. Versailles has been shuttered.
我们以王室成员被带回巴黎结束，那是一个极其屈辱的时刻。他们被鱼贩妇女和国民自卫军带回，国民议会最终尾随其后，他们被安置在杜伊勒里宫。那是上次的内容。现在让我们快进12个月到1790年底，看看革命进展到了什么程度。我想你可以称之为真正的革命已经持续了一年多。这距离攻占巴士底狱、三级会议转变为国民议会已经过去了一年多，基本上是代表们夺取了主权，从国王手中夺取了权力。故事的焦点现在不再是凡尔赛。凡尔赛已经被关闭了。
It's kind of become a museum. It has. And the focus is in Paris. So if you'd gone to Paris as a visitor, you would have noticed straight away at the end of 1790 how for ordinary people, life looks different. So there's a sort of unbridled sense of political freedom. People are wearing tricolor cockades. There are newspapers everywhere. The people are singing patriotic songs. They would sing them in the interval at the theatre and the opera. The revolution is a daily experience. It is a kind of living experience for Paris's hundreds of thousands of inhabitants. And Dominic, this is, I think, when William Wordsworth, the great romantic poet, goes to Paris and he writes his feelings about it, the famous lines, bliss was it in that dawn to be alive, but to be young was very heaven.
它已经变成了一座博物馆。确实如此。焦点在巴黎。所以如果你作为一个游客去巴黎，你会立刻注意到1790年底，对于普通人来说，生活看起来不同了。有一种肆无忌惮的政治自由感。人们戴着三色帽徽。到处都是报纸。人们在唱爱国歌曲。他们在剧院和歌剧院的中场休息时唱这些歌。革命是一种日常体验。对于巴黎成千上万的居民来说，这是一种鲜活的体验。多米尼克，我想这就是伟大的浪漫主义诗人威廉·华兹华斯去巴黎时写下他感受的时候，那句名言：在那黎明时分活着是多么幸福，而年轻本身就是天堂。
So that sense of joyous expectation of the entire world on the cusp of a brilliant new dawn is absolutely what is animating people in the streets, isn't it? It is absolutely, yeah. And there's a sense of people pushing all the time boundaries, people saying the unsayable, saying things they wouldn't have said a year ago or two years ago. It's a perfect example, actually, of a city that is living politics every day. And the tone is increasingly set by radical journalists. So you mentioned one, in fact, you mentioned a couple, Camille Desmoulins and Jean-Paul Marat. And the tone of their stuff is, I think, what we would now call populism. So they have, the one hand the people, the nation, who are virtuous, who are destined for greatness, but have been frustrated up till now by the machinations
所以那种对整个世界处于辉煌新黎明边缘的快乐期待，绝对是激励街头人们的东西，不是吗？绝对是，是的。人们有一种不断突破界限的感觉，人们在说那些不可言说的话，说那些一两年前或两年前他们不会说的话。这实际上是一个城市每天都在经历政治的完美例子。基调越来越多地由激进的记者设定。所以你提到了一个，事实上你提到了几个，卡米尔·德穆兰和让-保罗·马拉。我认为他们文章的基调就是我们现在所说的民粹主义。所以他们一方面是人民，是国家，他们是高尚的，注定要成就伟大，但到目前为止一直受到阴谋家
of conspirators. These could be foreigners, they could be priests, aristocrats. That sense of a hardening, that goes along with, I think, with the egalitarian democratic excitement that you get. There's also a sense that you also get in the National Assembly of excitement at the limits that you're pushing and the sense that actually everything could be new. So all traces of history could be effaced. France could be completely reborn and perhaps the world with it. And I guess that that sense of excitement is kind of what is new about the politics of the situation. Do you think? Yeah, I think so. And I think there's a sense of radical excitement that goes beyond anything that's been seen in previous revolutions. So,
的阻挠。这些人可能是外国人，可能是神职人员，也可能是贵族。这种强硬的感觉，我认为伴随着你所感受到的平等主义民主的兴奋。在国民议会中，你也会感受到一种对所突破的界限的兴奋，以及一种实际上一切都可以重塑的感觉。所以历史的所有痕迹都可以被抹去。法国可以彻底重生，也许世界也会随之重生。我想那种兴奋感就是这种情况下的政治新奇之处。你觉得呢？是的，我想是这样。而且我认为有一种激进的兴奋感，超越了以往任何革命中所见到的。所以，
of course, there's been a degree of excitement in the English Revolution, in the 17th century of the American Revolution. But this sense that everything that went before, you can get rid of it. You know better now. You can do something new. And of course, for the deputies of the National Assembly, that's both very exciting, but also potentially very exhausting. Sure. This is a lot of work to do, isn't it? Yeah. They have been working now for the best part of two years on a constitution, on a new framework for France, and they're rethinking everything. Government, law. You talked before about the most incendiary of all these things, which is the relationship of church and state.
当然，在17世纪的英国革命和美国革命中也有一定程度的兴奋。但这种感觉是，之前的一切，你都可以摆脱它。你现在更了解了。你可以做一些新的事情。当然，对于国民议会的代表们来说，这既非常令人兴奋，但也可能非常令人筋疲力尽。当然。这有很多工作要做，不是吗？是的。他们现在已经为宪法、为法国的新框架工作了近两年，他们正在重新思考一切。政府、法律。你之前谈到了所有这些事情中最具煽动性的一点，即教会与国家的关系。
And all of these things have massive repercussions in the countryside, and they're getting letters back the whole time. It's actually, the French Revolution is, if nothing else, it's a story about paperwork. So it's a story about young men basically being overwhelmed with enormous quantities of paperwork. And actually, the people at the National Assembly, of course, they are very excited, but they're also unbelievably tired. So historians who talk about this period notice that in their letters, they say all the time that they're suffering from massive headaches. They're not eating. They can't sleep. They are just overwhelmed. And actually, more and more, it's a hard core who are driving the politics. So there are about 1,200 people in the National Assembly, but only 400 of them are actually still turning up. The nobles and a lot of the priests are now staying away.
所有这些事情在农村都有巨大的反响，他们一直在收到回信。事实上，法国大革命如果说有什么特点的话，那就是一个关于文书工作的故事。所以这是一个关于年轻人基本上被海量的文书工作所淹没的故事。而且实际上，国民议会的人，当然，他们非常兴奋，但他们也累得难以置信。所以研究这一时期的历史学家注意到，他们在信中一直说他们患有严重的头痛。他们不吃饭。他们睡不着觉。他们只是被淹没了。而且实际上，越来越多的是核心人物在推动政治。所以国民议会里大约有1200人，但实际上只有400人还在出席。贵族和许多神职人员现在都避而不见。
And is that an expression of hostility to what is happening? Or is it nervousness? Or is it just they don't really identify with what's happening? I think it's all of those things. I think they're worried about the way it's going. I think many of them are outraged at the course it has already taken. And I think there's a sense
这是一种对正在发生的事情的敌意表现吗？还是紧张？还是他们只是不认同正在发生的事情？我认为这些因素都有。我认为他们担心事态的发展方向。我认为他们中的许多人对已经采取的路线感到愤怒。而且我认为有一种感觉
that suddenly these people, the old guard, if you like, are in a world that they don't understand. They no longer want to be part of it. And so they've gone back often to their states in La France Profonde.
突然之间，这些人，如果你愿意的话，旧卫队，处于一个他们不理解的世界中。他们不再想成为其中的一部分。所以他们经常回到他们在法国深处的庄园。
There is also a sense, though, isn't there, that even as they are pushing into a bright new future, they are also increasingly starting to look to ancient exemplars, which are Republican exemplars.
不过，也有一种感觉，不是吗？即使他们正在向一个光明的新未来推进，他们也越来越多地开始寻找古代的典范，即共和主义的典范。
That's true. And particularly in the kind of the clubs that we talked about, the Jacobin Club at the end of the previous episode. The exemplars are becoming Republican, aren't they? Well, so the Jacobin Club that you ended with last time, officially the Society of the Friends of the Constitution that meets in this old monastery very close to the National Assembly. If you went into the Jacobin Club, they would have busts of the Constitution that meets in this old monastery very close to the National Assembly.
那是真的。特别是在我们上一集结尾谈到的那种俱乐部里，雅各宾俱乐部。典范正在变成共和主义的，不是吗？那么，你上次结束时提到的雅各宾俱乐部，正式名称是宪法之友协会，它在国民议会附近的一座古老修道院里开会。如果你走进雅各宾俱乐部，他们会有宪法的半身像，它在国民议会附近的一座古老修道院里开会。
If you went into the Jacobin Club, they would have busts of Brutus, Cato, Benjamin Franklin. They had framed copies of the Declaration of the Rights of Man. There is a sort of sense that you're in, I mean, it's a kind of metropolitan elite, but it's a Republican. It is. Brutus and Cato are both famous people who fought against an autocrat. But they don't see themselves as Republicans at this stage. That's the interesting thing. They're almost unconsciously Republicans, I would say. Actually, on the clubs, the Jacquemin Club, there's a network of them.
如果你走进雅各宾俱乐部，他们会有布鲁图斯、加图、本杰明·富兰克林的半身像。他们有装裱好的《人权宣言》副本。有一种感觉，你身处其中，我的意思是，这是一种大都市精英，但它是共和主义的。确实如此。布鲁图斯和加图都是著名的反抗独裁者的人。但在这个阶段，他们并不认为自己是共和主义者。这很有趣。我想说，他们几乎是无意识的共和主义者。实际上，关于俱乐部，雅各宾俱乐部，有一个网络。
It's a bit sort of Soho House. So they've opened basically subsidiaries all across France. There are about 400 of them by the beginning of 1791. With spas. Yes. Swimming pools. Yeah. And they look very similar.
这有点像苏豪区俱乐部。所以他们基本上在法国各地开设了分部。到1791年初，大约有400个。有水疗中心。是的。游泳池。是的。而且它们看起来非常相似。
And dare I say, the influences of the time go to the local Jacobin club, because that is where the aspirational, upwardly mobile, the people with momentum, with social and cultural momentum, where they go. But it's also a sign of a kind of factionalism and of a kind of radicalization, a radical ratchet, because there are lots of other clubs competing to outflank the Jacobin on the left. And the most famous one of this is a club called the Society of the Rights of Man, which is called the Cordelier Club. This meets on the left bank near the Latin Quarter. It's the sort of artistic, publishing, journalistic district. The tone is set there at the Cordelier by people like Desmoulins and Marat. And they are really pushing two things. One is saying the revolution needs to go much further. Democracy, egalitarianism, the people's rights and all that stuff. And then the other side of it is that very aggressive populist side. So it's at the Cordilliers that people are going on about conspiracies the whole time. And Dominic, the issue of democracy, because that then begs the question, which I'm sure people have been wondering about who actually has the vote in all this.
而且我敢说，当时的影响力会去当地的雅各宾俱乐部，因为那是那些有抱负的、向上流动的、有动力的人，有社会和文化动力的人去的地方。但这也是一种派系主义和一种激进化、一种激进棘轮的标志，因为还有许多其他俱乐部在左翼竞争以超越雅各宾派。其中最著名的是一个叫人权协会的俱乐部，被称为科德利埃俱乐部。它在左岸靠近拉丁区的地方开会。那是艺术、出版、新闻区。科德利埃俱乐部的基调是由德穆兰和马拉这样的人设定的。他们确实在推动两件事。一是说革命需要走得更远。民主、平等主义、人民的权利等等。然后另一面是那种非常激进的民粹主义一面。所以是在科德利埃俱乐部，人们一直在谈论阴谋。多米尼克，民主的问题，因为这引出了一个问题，我相信人们一直在想，到底谁在这一切中有投票权。
The constitution, as it's being structured, has come up with the notion of active and passive citizens, hasn't it? Yeah, that's right. That active citizens are basically males over 25 who pay a certain amount of money in tax or whatever each year, and they have voting rights and everyone else doesn't. And that, of course, includes women. So there is scope there for a leftward push inherent in the kind of model of democracy that's being structured. There is, absolutely. So that's one of the things that is, as it were, pushing the revolution, a sense of democratic excitement and a sense that you can actually, there are always more boundaries to cross. Simon Sharma says of these clubs, so there are these kind of fraternal societies, as they call it, that are associated with the
宪法在构建时，提出了积极公民和消极公民的概念，不是吗？是的，没错。积极公民基本上是25岁以上每年缴纳一定税款的男性，他们有投票权，而其他人则没有。当然，这包括女性。所以，在所构建的民主模式中，存在着向左推进的空间。确实存在，绝对是。所以这就是推动革命的事情之一，一种民主的兴奋感，以及一种你实际上可以，总有更多的界限可以跨越的感觉。西蒙·沙马谈到这些俱乐部时说，所以有一些他们称之为兄弟会的协会，与
Cordelia, that some of them in some ways become even more radical. And he says their rhetoric was Rousseau with a hoarse voice and sharpened with bloody-minded impatience. And that bloody-minded impatience is very important because in late 1790, early 1791, bread prices are still veryience. And that bloody minded impatience is very important because in late 1790, early 1791, bread prices are still very high. And in fact, inflation has gone through the roof because the government is now printing a lot of paper money, assignats, they're called. So when you have high inflation, you have labor unrest because people say their wages aren't high enough to meet their outgoings. So there was a wave of strikes through the winter, 1791 in Paris, that basically it adds to the sense of unrest and anarchy and things being out of control. It's not good for the deputies in the National Assembly's blood pressure because they're living
科德利埃俱乐部有关，其中一些在某些方面变得更加激进。他说他们的言辞是声音嘶哑的卢梭，并带着血腥的急躁情绪变得尖锐。那种血腥的急躁非常重要，因为在1790年底、1791年初，面包价格仍然非常高。事实上，通货膨胀已经失控，因为政府现在正在印制大量的纸币，即指券。所以当你通货膨胀严重时，就会出现劳工骚乱，因为人们说他们的工资不足以支付开支。因此，1791年冬天巴黎发生了一波罢工，这基本上增加了动荡、无政府状态和局势失控的感觉。这对国民议会代表们的血压没有好处，因为他们生活
in the midst of all this. They're living in Paris and they look out of their window when they get up in the morning and they see crowds on the streets, people shouting, people saying, where are the fruits that we were expecting? All of that stuff. And they have sat in the assembly and had the poor and the starving burst in and kind of demand bread, haven't they? Back when they were in Versailles, the women from Paris who took the king and queen back to the capital. They have. So that's a warning to them that what's happened to the royal family could easily happen to them. Sitting on the edge of a volcano, Dominic. Theyic they are tom they're dancing on the brim of a tinderbox if that's possible so some of the more farsighted members of the national assembly had seen this coming
在这一切之中。他们住在巴黎，早上起床时向窗外看，看到街上的人群，人们在喊叫，人们在说，我们期待的成果在哪里？所有这些东西。他们坐在议会里，看着穷人和饥饿的人冲进来要求面包，不是吗？回到他们在凡尔赛时，来自巴黎的妇女把国王和王后带回了首都。他们确实这样做了。所以这对他们是一个警告，王室发生的事情很容易发生在他们身上。坐在火山边缘，多米尼克。他们，汤姆，如果可能的话，他们正在火药桶的边缘跳舞，所以国民议会中一些更有远见的成员已经预见到了这一点
had actually said even years earlier in 1789 you know actually turning the estates general into a national assembly having a new constitution it's not going to solve the financial problems overnight, nor is it going to give people cheaper bread. And actually, one of the people who noticed this was the Comte de Mirabeau, who we talked about before, this gigantic, incredibly ugly, very successful with the ladies. Yet another of the figures in the French Revolution with bad skin. Exactly. He said in early 1791, the people have been promised more than can be promised.
甚至在几年前的1789年就说过，你知道，实际上把三级会议变成国民议会，制定一部新宪法，并不能在一夜之间解决财政问题，也不会给人们提供更便宜的面包。事实上，注意到这一点的人之一是米拉波伯爵，我们之前谈到过他，这个巨大、极其丑陋、非常受女士欢迎的人。法国大革命中又一个皮肤不好的人物。正是如此。他在1791年初说，人们被承诺了太多无法承诺的东西。
They have been given hopes that will be impossible to realize. In the last analysis, he said, they'll judge the revolution by this fact alone. Are they better off? Do they have more work? Is that work better paid? So he can see that you've got to give people concrete results. Now, Mirabeau, a lot of people have thought he would be the man to do that. He would preside over a transition to a constitutional monarchy in the British model. Certainly he thought that himself. But actually, because he thinks that so conspicuously, a lot of people in the National Assembly opposed to him. And there's a sense that he's losing momentum in early 1791. Not least because he's become very close to the royal family.
他们被给予了无法实现的希望。归根结底，他说，他们将仅凭这一事实来评判革命。他们过得更好吗？他们有更多的工作吗？那份工作报酬更高吗？所以他能看出你必须给人们具体的结果。现在，米拉波，很多人认为他会是那个做到这一点的人。他将主持向英国模式的君主立宪制的过渡。当然他自己也这么认为。但实际上，因为他如此显眼地这样认为，国民议会中很多人反对他。而且有一种感觉，他在1791年初正在失去动力。不仅因为他与王室走得很近。
So he's been taking money from them. Yeah. And do you know who the go-between was who established contact? Andy Caddick, Tom. No, no. It was Monsieur Léonard again. The hairdresser. The hairdresser. Oh, no.
所以他一直在从他们那里拿钱。是的。你知道是谁作为中间人建立了联系吗？安迪·卡迪克，汤姆。不，不。又是莱昂纳德先生。那个理发师。那个理发师。哦，不。
He pops up in all kinds of unexpected places according to his own version. Okay. Well, that's... Who knew that was coming? But then Mirabeau dies in 1791. So he's out of the equation. So he's basically the only major figure
根据他自己的说法，他出现在各种意想不到的地方。好吧。那是……谁知道会发生这种事？但后来米拉波在1791年去世了。所以他退出了竞争。所以他基本上是唯一一个
in the entire revolution who dies in his bed. Is he? Pretty much, don't you think? There's the Abbé de Sierre, isn't there, who famously says, of the French Revolution, I survived. And Talleyrand. Yeah, and Talleyrand.
在整个革命中死在床上的主要人物。是吗？差不多，你不觉得吗？有西耶斯神父，不是吗？他曾有名言，关于法国大革命，我活了下来。还有塔列朗。是的，还有塔列朗。
But Mirabeau is, I mean, of all the kind of the titanic figures, he's the only one who doesn't end up. It's amazing how many people in this story basically end up having an appointment with a guillotine, isn't it? I mean, extraordinary. Anyway, so Mirabeau's out of the equation there's a group of sort of moderate jacobin and the sort of totemic figure is a guy called antoine barnav who's a lawyer from grenoble
但米拉波，我的意思是，在所有那些泰坦式的人物中，他是唯一一个没有以那种方式结束的人。这个故事里有那么多人基本上最终都与断头台有约，这真是太神奇了，不是吗？我的意思是，非凡。无论如何，米拉波退出了竞争，有一群温和的雅各宾派，图腾式的人物是一个叫安托万·巴纳夫的人，他是格勒诺布尔的一名律师
so remember how we said that grenoble was the motor of the revolution so this young man from grenoble barnav with his pals is now basically directing the momentum of the revolution and actually what they want to do they're like, actually the revolution has gone far enough now. You know, France has had enough politics. Let's calm things down. Let's bring in a few of the restrictions, like calm the press down, calm the strikes down, all of this kind of thing. And actually they think the key to this is really to get a deal with the king. Let's get the king back, get a constitution, get him back in his sort of rightful place,
所以记得我们说过格勒诺布尔是革命的引擎，所以这个来自格勒诺布尔的年轻人巴纳夫和他的伙伴们现在基本上在引导革命的动力，实际上他们想做的是，他们觉得，革命现在已经走得够远了。你知道，法国已经经历了足够的政治。让我们让事情平静下来。让我们引入一些限制，比如让媒体平静下来，让罢工平静下来，所有这些事情。实际上他们认为关键在于与国王达成协议。让我们把国王带回来，制定一部宪法，让他回到他应有的位置，
presiding over a constitutional monarchy. The Bon Père. Yeah, the Bon Père of France, exactly. And hopefully the streets will quieten down and things will return to normal. The question, of course, is, is Louis XVI somebody they can do business with? And they think he is. And they've got good reason to think that.
主持君主立宪制。好父亲。是的，法国的好父亲，正是如此。希望街道会安静下来，事情会恢复正常。当然，问题是，路易十六是一个他们可以与之共事的人吗？他们认为他是。而且他们有充分的理由这样认为。
Because you know when you did that amazing set piece about him being brought back and Marie Antoinette on the balcony and the terrible scenes. So obviously after that, they're pretty traumatized, Louis and Marie Antoinette. And they didn't go out of the Tuileries for weeks, for months. They didn't even go to walk in the garden. They were so depressed, basically being turned into prisoners. But eventually they surface and Louis actually seems like, you know, it seems like he will work with the revolution on the anniversary of the fall of the Bastille in 1790. He goes to the altar of the fatherland, as it's called, and the
因为你知道当你做那个关于他被带回来、玛丽·安托瓦内特在阳台上以及可怕场景的精彩片段时。所以很明显在那之后，他们受到了很大的创伤，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特。他们几周、几个月都没有走出杜伊勒里宫。他们甚至没有去花园散步。他们非常沮丧，基本上变成了囚犯。但最终他们露面了，路易实际上看起来，你知道，看起来他会与革命合作，在1790年攻占巴士底狱周年纪念日。他去了所谓的祖国祭坛，以及
Chant de Mars, and he swears an oath that he will, when they finally get round to doing the constitution, he will uphold it. And he wears a kind of plain black coat, doesn't he? He does. There's no kind of Versailles swagger. Exactly. And people say, listen, he's not a bad man. No one's ever thought he was a bad man, by the way. They think he's a bit useless. He's a bit weak. He eats too much. He drinks too much. And he's much too interested in hunting.
战神广场，他发誓，当他们最终制定宪法时，他会维护它。他穿了一件朴素的黑色外套，不是吗？他穿了。没有凡尔赛的那种傲慢。正是如此。人们说，听着，他不是个坏人。顺便说一句，从来没有人认为他是个坏人。他们认为他有点没用。他有点软弱。他吃得太多。他喝得太多。而且他对打猎太感兴趣了。
I mean, he's very, very fat by this point. He is very fat now. The more things go against him, the more he eats. But when this gigantic figure appears and swears the oath, everybody says, well, Louis is a very religious man. Everybody knows that. It's the one thing people know about him. So for him to swear this oath, he would not lie. He must be determined to work with the revolution,
我的意思是，到这个时候他非常非常胖。他现在非常胖。事情越是不顺，他吃得就越多。但当这个巨大的人物出现并宣誓时，每个人都说，好吧，路易是一个非常虔诚的人。每个人都知道这一点。这是人们关于他唯一知道的事情。所以他发誓，他不会撒谎。他一定决心与革命合作，
to accept the new order. He's a well-meaning guy and he's the father of his people and isn't that great but the reality is they are deceived so even in 1789 we know now historians found letters in the 20th century that he had been writing to other monarchs like the king of spain his relative and he had said i hate the revolution everything that they have extorted from me has been under duress i owe it to myself i owe it to other monarchs like the King of Spain, his relative. And he had said, I hate the revolution. Everything that they have extorted from me has been under duress. I owe it to myself.
接受新秩序。他是个好心人，他是他人民的父亲，这难道不好吗？但现实是他们被欺骗了，所以即使在1789年，我们现在知道，历史学家在20世纪发现了信件，他一直在写信给其他君主，比如西班牙国王，他的亲戚，他说我讨厌革命，他们从我这里勒索的一切都是在胁迫下进行的，我欠我自己的，我欠其他君主，比如西班牙国王，他的亲戚。他说，我讨厌革命。他们从我这里勒索的一切都是在胁迫下进行的。我欠我自己的。
I owe it to my children. I owe it to my entire family, he said, to make sure that I rebuild royal authority. I don't let this get out of hand. And of course, he's being fed in all this by Mary Antoinette because she is dead against the revolution. She's been completely traumatized. She has. You don't understand why she's dead against it. She's been abused. She's been completely traumatized. She has. You don't understand why she's dead against it. She's been abused.
我欠我的孩子。我欠我的整个家庭，他说，要确保我重建王权。我不能让这种情况失控。当然，他这一切都被玛丽·安托瓦内特喂养，因为她坚决反对革命。她受到了彻底的创伤。她确实受到了。你不知道为什么她坚决反对它。她受到了虐待。她受到了彻底的创伤。她确实受到了。你不知道为什么她坚决反对它。她受到了虐待。
She's been mistreated. She says these people are monsters and what they represent is evil. But equally, it's not great advice, is it? No, it isn't great advice. I think you could say, Tom. But Louis is primed to believe it because he's horrified in particular
她受到了不公正的对待。她说这些人是怪物，他们代表的是邪恶。但同样，这不是什么好建议，不是吗？不，这不是什么好建议。我想你可以这么说，汤姆。但路易准备相信它，因为他特别感到震惊
about the religious thing. I mean, I don't think you can underestimate the importance of that. But Louis was, you know, he was an anointed king. I can't believe I'm the person saying this on the podcast. Carry on, Dominic. He's an anointed king. He takes mass every day. He had written in his journals when he was a boy
关于宗教的事情。我的意思是，我不认为你可以低估它的重要性。但路易是，你知道，他是一位受膏的国王。我不敢相信我是播客上说这话的人。继续，多米尼克。他是一位受膏的国王。他每天做弥撒。他小时候在日记里写过
that God had chosen him to be king, and he took this really seriously. And when it comes to the great hullabaloo about the civil constitution of the clergy, the fact that priests have to swear an oath to the constitution and that the Pope then, at the beginning of 1791, says, don't do this, you're in danger of excommunication if you do it. For Louis, this is the most horrendous, horrendous dilemma. He's caught between his country and his God,
上帝选择了他成为国王，他非常认真地对待这一点。当谈到关于教士公民宪法的巨大骚动时，即教士必须宣誓效忠宪法，而教皇在1791年初说，不要这样做，如果你这样做，你就有被逐出教会的危险。对于路易来说，这是最可怕、最可怕的困境。他夹在国家和上帝之间，
and for him it's just an intolerable position to be in. A different man a more cynical character a teller or type figure captain bentine from the custer series he could absolutely have dealt with this louis the 16th psychologically and i guess because the institutional pressures of his family his role the weight of history he just can't do it. So why doesn't he run away? Why doesn't he make a break for it? Because that's, of course, what so many of his counsellors have been saying ever since 1789. And the reason he doesn't, as all his biographers say, he's well-meaning and he's earnest and he's...
对他来说，这只是一个无法忍受的位置。一个不同的人，一个更愤世嫉俗的角色，一个塔列朗类型的人物，卡斯特系列中的本廷船长，他绝对可以处理这个问题，路易十六在心理上，我想因为他家庭的制度压力、他的角色、历史的重量，他就是做不到。那么他为什么不逃跑呢？他为什么不冲出去呢？因为那当然是自1789年以来他的许多顾问一直在说的。他没有这样做的原因，正如他所有的传记作者所说，他心地善良，他很诚恳，而且他……
Indecisive. He's indecisive. He's a ditherer. He doesn't want to do the wrong thing. So he just sits there paral and paralyzed now and there seems to have been a change at the end of 1790 and he says okay we'll draw up a contingency plan all these plans about going to the east going to the frontier garrisons and there were loyal troops there fine tell me how this would work and the man who's in charge drawing up the plan is our old old friend, top Swedish sort of...
优柔寡断。他优柔寡断。他是个犹豫不决的人。他不想做错事。所以他只是坐在那里，现在瘫痪了，1790年底似乎发生了一些变化，他说好吧，我们将制定一个应急计划，所有这些关于去东方、去边境驻军的计划，那里有忠诚的部队，很好，告诉我这怎么运作，负责制定计划的人是我们老朋友，顶级的瑞典那种……
Swarf dasher. I was going to say a bounder, but he's not a bounder, is he? No, I don't think he is. He'd be played by Roger Moore, but he'd behave in a good way. And he's Axel von Fersen, the Swedish count and friend of Marianne Swannett.
花花公子。我本来想说是个无赖，但他不是无赖，是吗？不，我不认为他是。他会被罗杰·摩尔扮演，但他会以一种好的方式行事。他是阿克塞尔·冯·费森，瑞典伯爵，玛丽·安托瓦内特的朋友。
And he draws up an excellent plan. He keeps coming to the Tuileries Palace and he's in disguise when they're making the plans. I mean, he's the kind of person who would love a disguise. Yeah, totally. Because he's a swashbuckling. He's the Scarlet Pimpernel, basically, isn't he? Yeah.
他制定了一个出色的计划。他一直来杜伊勒里宫，制定计划时他乔装打扮。我的意思是，他是那种喜欢伪装的人。是的，完全是。因为他是个侠客。他基本上是红花侠，不是吗？是的。
So him and Monsieur Léonard are both clearly figures who kind of love the sense of conspiracy, dressing up, carrying secret messages, but in a slightly ostentatious way. There's a Sunday night BBC Two drama in Monsieur Léonard and Axel von Fersen solving crimes in revolutionary Paris. I don't think they'd do it very well. A camp hairdresser and a kind of dashing Swede. So Alexander Skarsgård could play Axel von Fersen. Yeah, he could.
所以他和莱昂纳德先生显然都是喜欢阴谋、打扮、携带秘密信息的人，但方式有点招摇。BBC二台周日晚上有一部关于莱昂纳德先生和阿克塞尔·冯·费森在革命巴黎破案的剧。我不认为他们会做得很好。一个娘娘腔的理发师和一个潇洒的瑞典人。所以亚历山大·斯卡斯加德可以扮演阿克塞尔·冯·费森。是的，他可以。
I don't know who would play Monsieur Léonard. Mathieu Amalric, the French actor. Anyway, let's buy the buy. Yeah, let's buy the buy. Yeah, it is by the by. He draws up this plan to get out in disguise. The issue that he has is his plan was initially for Louis and Marie Antoinette. And he says, it would be better for you to travel separately.
我不知道谁会扮演莱昂纳德先生。马修·阿马立克，法国演员。无论如何，这不重要。是的，这不重要。是的，这不重要。他制定了这个乔装逃跑的计划。他面临的问题是，他的计划最初是为路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特制定的。他说，你们分开旅行会更好。
They say, there's no way we'll do that. We have to take our children. We have to take the king's sister, Elizabeth, who's hanging around in the palace with them. Marie Antoinette also says, I'd like to take two nannies for the children and there are three sort of young noblemen who they want to take as bodyguards. So now the party is basically 11 people and there's the hairdresser but he's going to travel separately. But he gets sent out on a kind of scoping mission.
他们说，我们绝不会那样做。我们必须带上我们的孩子。我们必须带上国王的妹妹伊丽莎白，她和他们一起在宫殿里闲逛。玛丽·安托瓦内特还说，我想带两个保姆照顾孩子，还有三个年轻的贵族，他们想带他们作为保镖。所以现在队伍基本上有11个人，还有一个理发师，但他会分开旅行。但他被派去执行某种侦察任务。
He does indeed. So end of 1790, early 1791, they basically, they know who they want to take. And Axel von Fersen looks at this and he says, well, this is too many people for one coach. We're going to have to have more than, we have a one very big coach and another coach for the nannies. And he commissions the coach that will take them. So it's called a Berlin. It's a kind of luxury coach. It took three months to build it.
他确实去了。所以1790年底，1791年初，他们基本上知道他们想带谁。阿克塞尔·冯·费森看了看，说，这对于一辆马车来说人太多了。我们必须有更多，我们有一辆非常大的马车和另一辆给保姆的马车。他委托制造了带他们走的马车。所以它被称为柏林马车。这是一种豪华马车。建造它花了三个月。
It cost 6,000 French pounds. A lot of books, a lot of general histories of the revolution say it was a carriage and a luxury coach. It took three months to build it. It cost 6,000 French pounds. A lot of books, a lot of general histories of the revolution say it was a carriage and it looked inconspicuous. It absolutely was not. It's enormous, isn't it?
它花费了6000法郎。很多书，很多关于革命的通史都说它是一辆马车，一辆豪华马车。建造它花了三个月。它花费了6000法郎。很多书，很多关于革命的通史都说它是一辆马车，看起来不显眼。它绝对不是。它很大，不是吗？
It was like a luxury limo of coaches. It's black, but it has a yellow frame, so it's very conspicuous. And inside, Timothy Tackett, who wrote this wonderful book
它就像马车里的豪华轿车。它是黑色的，但有一个黄色的框架，所以非常显眼。在里面，蒂莫西·塔克特，写了这本精彩的书
about the flight of the king, says it has a leather interior padded seats a picnic set bottle racks and a leather covered chamber pot so it's
关于国王的逃亡，说它有皮革内饰、软垫座椅、野餐套装、瓶架和皮革覆盖的便壶，所以它
like a private jet of coaches absolutely and it kind of raises the question that even at this point do they understand what they're up against
就像马车里的私人飞机，绝对是。这引出了一个问题，即使在这一点上，他们是否了解他们所面临的对手
they're not really taking the danger seriously they could have done a kind of Charles II yeah you know hiding in oak trees kind of approach They could have done a kind of Charles II, you know, hiding in oak
他们并没有真正认真对待危险，他们本可以像查理二世那样，你知道，躲在橡树里的那种方式。他们本可以像查理二世那样，你知道，躲在橡树
trees kind of approach. They could have really gone undercover. They could have not traveled with coaches just for a week or something. They could have foregone the luxury, but they just can't bring themselves to do it. I think there's three things there. So I think the Charles II embarrassment is a brilliant one. Because of course, Charles II faces, I mean, worse pressures during his life, but here's all those things that Louis isn course, Charles II faces, I mean, worse pressures during his life, but here's all those things that Louis isn't. Charles II is very cunning. He can be quite malign. He's incredibly cynical and he wins, right? He plays his cards brilliantly. So there's that element to it. I think they don't understand France, as we will see.
里的那种方式。他们本可以真正潜伏起来。他们本可以不只坐马车旅行一周左右。他们本可以放弃奢侈，但他们就是无法做到。我想这里有三件事。所以我认为查理二世的尴尬是一个绝妙的例子。因为当然，查理二世面临着，我的意思是，他一生中面临着更糟糕的压力，但这里有所有路易不是的东西。查理二世非常狡猾。他可以相当恶毒。他极其愤世嫉俗，而且他赢了，对吧？他把牌打得非常漂亮。所以有那个因素。我认为他们不了解法国，正如我们将看到的。
Of course, because they haven't been going out into the country at all, have they? I mean, they've just been in Versailles most of their lives. No, they don't understand France. They're such prisoners, aren't they, of their own upbringing. And they've lived in that extraordinary environment of Versailles and they cannot conceive of doing a Charles II and just going completely incognito. And the irony of it is that Marie Antoinette, of all people, is the person who kind of loves the ideal of simplicity of escaping hidebound convention and yet at the end she is destroyed by her inability to realize what that
当然，因为他们根本没有去过乡下，不是吗？我的意思是，他们一生大部分时间都在凡尔赛。不，他们不了解法国。他们是他们自己教养的囚犯，不是吗？他们生活在凡尔赛那种非凡的环境中，他们无法想象像查理二世那样完全隐姓埋名。讽刺的是，玛丽·安托瓦内特竟然是那个喜欢简单、逃避陈规陋习的理想的人，然而最终她却因为无法意识到那
might actually mean yeah no I think that's true I mean she loves the dressing up well as we'll see but I mean it's kind of you know I want to be like common people it's very pulp yeah there's kind of real cosplay about it so are they going to do it that's the question and actually it's still hanging in the air a bit in the early months of 1791. And then something happens that pushes Louis over the edge. He wants to go to, they've got a house at St. Cloud, sort of country house. And he wants to go there for Easter because basically there are priests there who have not sworn the oath to the constitution so far, who are sort of still loyal to Rome,
可能意味着什么而被摧毁。是的，不，我认为那是真的。我的意思是，她喜欢打扮，正如我们将看到的，但我的意思是，这有点像，你知道，我想变得像普通人一样，这非常流行，是的，这有一种真正的角色扮演感。所以他们要这样做吗？这是个问题，实际上在1791年初的几个月里，它仍然悬而未决。然后发生了一件事，把路易推向了边缘。他想去，他们在圣克卢有一个房子，某种乡间别墅。他想去那里过复活节，因为基本上那里有到目前为止还没有宣誓效忠宪法的教士，他们某种程度上仍然忠于罗马，
as it were. And he wants to go and have easter with them and news of this gets out in paris a huge crowd assembles when he and marion trinette go to leave the tuileries they are blocked by the crowd in their carriage and they are have to sit there being abused by the crowd for almost two hours and marion trinette is in floods of tears louis is really shaken it is clear to them now that they are prisoners. And after this, actually, instead of feeling sorry forarnet say, we can't live like this. We have to get out. And what then happens is he is very clever because the very next day he goes to the National Assembly for the first time in a year and reiterates how keen he is to work with them and to uphold the Constitution.
正如他们所说。他想去和他们一起过复活节，这个消息在巴黎传开了，当他和玛丽·安托瓦内特离开杜伊勒里宫时，一大群人聚集起来，他们被马车里的人群挡住了，他们不得不坐在那里被人群辱骂了近两个小时，玛丽·安托瓦内特泪流满面，路易真的被吓坏了，现在很清楚他们是囚犯。在这之后，实际上，他没有感到抱歉，而是说，我们不能这样生活。我们必须离开。然后发生的事情是他非常聪明，因为第二天他一年来第一次去国民议会，重申他有多么渴望与他们合作并维护宪法。
And the National Assembly, especially the more moderate deputies, this is what they want to hear. And they're like, oh, brilliant, Louis is really coming round. You know, he's really behaving well these days, isn't this great? But while the National Assembly are congratulating themselves that everything's going to be fine, Louis and Axel and co are finalising the plan. The plan is they will get out of the city and they will head for the garrison town of Montmedy, which is on the border of the Austrian Netherlands, now Belgium.
而国民议会，尤其是那些更温和的代表，这是他们想听到的。他们说，哦，太棒了，路易真的回心转意了。你知道，他这些天表现得真的很好，这难道不好吗？但当国民议会为一切都会好起来而自我祝贺时，路易和阿克塞尔等人正在敲定计划。计划是他们将离开城市，前往蒙梅迪的驻军城镇，那里在奥属尼德兰的边界，现在是比利时。
And there, the Marquis de Bouilly is waiting with Swiss and German troops who they think will be more loyal than French speaking troops. And it will all be great. Now, there was a direct road that went through Reims, where Louis had been crowned, and it went through a lot of empty countryside and was a good road to take. And the Marquis de Bois says, go that way. And Louis said, no, no, no, because I was crowned in Reims, there'll be people who will recognize me. So it'd be much better to go this other road, which admittedly goes through lots of small towns and villages. But of course, Louis is very confident that in the small towns and villages, there will be no problem because even if he is recognized, those people will surely still be loyal to the king.
在那里，布耶侯爵正在等待瑞士和德国的军队，他们认为这些军队会比讲法语的军队更忠诚。一切都会很棒。现在，有一条直接的路经过兰斯，路易在那里加冕，它经过许多空旷的乡村，是一条很好的路。布耶侯爵说，走那条路。路易说，不，不，不，因为我在兰斯加冕，会有认出我的人。所以走这条路会好得多，虽然不可否认它经过许多小城镇和村庄。但当然，路易非常有信心，在小城镇和村庄里，不会有问题，因为即使他被认出来，那些人肯定仍然会忠于国王。
These aren't the sort of urban freaks of the Jacobin. These are ordinary French men and women, decent people. Salt of the earth. Salt of the earth. Exactly. But the real question is, you raised this at the beginning, Tom, what's the end game? What is the point? Let's imagine he gets to Montmedy and he rendezvous with the troops.
这些不是雅各宾派的城市怪胎。这些是普通的法国男人和女人，正派的人。大地之盐。大地之盐。正是如此。但真正的问题是，你在一开始就提出了这一点，汤姆，终局是什么？意义何在？让我们想象他到达了蒙梅迪并与部队会合。
What then? I mean, does he have enough troops? It's the first question. There are attachments of Swiss troops and German troops, but we know that commanders had said to him in 1789, we don't really have enough troops to take. Paris is a big place. We're not confident we have enough troops to take Paris if the population of the city is against us. Of course, the National Guard are in Paris and and there will be French-speaking troops who will rally shortly to the National Assembly. So there's that. The Austrian ambassador who was in touch with Marion Trenet,
那接下来呢？我的意思是，他有足够的军队吗？这是第一个问题。虽然有瑞士军队和德国军队的增援，但我们知道，1789年时指挥官们就曾对他说过，我们确实没有足够的兵力去占领。巴黎是个大地方。如果城市居民反对我们，我们没有信心能有足够的兵力占领巴黎。当然，国民自卫军在巴黎，而且会有讲法语的军队很快倒戈支持国民议会。所以情况就是这样。当时与玛丽·安托瓦内特保持联系的奥地利大使，
who was what we now call a Belgian, because he's a French speaker from the Austrian Netherlands, he had been writing to Marion Trenet, and he had said, don't do this, because if it works, if you get out of the capital, basically you're going to declare civil war and the French people will suffer immeasurably and you might not even win. But he then says to her, I don't think you will get out. I think every village and town you go through will be against you. And if you are caught, it will be a catastrophe for you and for the monarchy. And the Austrian are caught, it will be a catastrophe for you and for
他就是我们现在所说的比利时人，因为他是来自奥属尼德兰的法语使用者，他一直在给玛丽·安托瓦内特写信，他说，别这么做，因为如果成功了，如果你逃离了首都，基本上你就是在发动内战，法国人民将遭受不可估量的痛苦，而且你甚至可能赢不了。但他随后又对她说，我不认为你能逃得出去。我想你经过的每一个村庄和城镇都会反对你。如果你被抓住了，这对你和君主制来说都将是一场灾难。而奥地利人如果被抓住，这对你和
the monarchy. And the Austrian ambassador had actually said, listen, I just think you have to wait this out. The mad creations of the revolutionaries will collapse by themselves. But for perfectly understandable human reasons, Louis and Marion Swannett don't want to wait. They don't believe the revolution will collapse, but more importantly, they have this, I think this terrible sense of doom hanging over them that they're in this palace in the center of paris yeah kind of echoing yeah and the streets outside seething with tension it's not easing it is growing because people are angry that the bread prices are still high that the conspiracies of their imagination are still fettered well there is a conspiracy i mean let's be frank about it and marie antoinette
君主制来说都将是一场灾难。奥地利大使实际上曾说，听着，我认为你只能静观其变。革命者那些疯狂的创造物会自行崩溃。但出于完全可以理解的人性原因，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特不想等待。他们不相信革命会崩溃，但更重要的是，他们心中有一种挥之不去的、可怕的末日感，他们身处巴黎市中心的这座宫殿里，是的，回声阵阵，是的，外面的街道上充满了紧张气氛，这种气氛并没有缓解，反而愈演愈烈，因为人们愤怒，面包价格依然高昂，他们想象中的阴谋依然受到束缚，好吧，确实存在阴谋，我的意思是，我们坦率地说，玛丽·安托瓦内特
has heard people of the kind that she hears outside the Tuileries back in Versailles demanding that her guts be made into cocades. So I think she's entitled to feel a bit twitchy. Of course. And they've got the children. Just as parents, they would want to get their children out of this environment. So the dais cast, as it were, Tom, the decision decision is made Rubicon is about to be crossed it is there are various postponements and delays
听过她在杜伊勒里宫外听到的那种人，在凡尔赛时就要求把她的内脏做成帽徽。所以我认为她感到有点不安是有道理的。当然。而且他们还有孩子。仅仅作为父母，他们也会想把孩子带离这种环境。所以，骰子已经掷下了，汤姆，决定已经做出，卢比孔河即将被跨越，虽然有各种推迟和延误，
but the date is set for Monday the 20th of June wow high drama so let's take a break there
但日期定在了6月20日星期一。哇，高潮迭起，那我们先休息一下。
and when we come back we will find out if the attempt by the Royal Family to escape succeeds massive tension I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host the royal family to escape succeeds. Massive tension.
当我们回来时，我们将揭晓王室的逃亡尝试是否成功。巨大的紧张感。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持王室逃亡尝试是否成功。巨大的紧张感。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点点演艺圈八卦。在我们的问答环节，我们会揭开娱乐界的幕布，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集
and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History. Dominic, we are entering the final segment of this eight-part epic on the beginnings of the French Revolution.
以及提前购买现场演出门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。你好，欢迎回到《剩下的就是历史》。多米尼克，我们正在进入这个关于法国大革命起源的八集史诗系列的最后一部分。
All is set for the attempt by the royal family to make their escape from Paris. How does it go? So the date, as we said, was set for Monday the 20th of June. And that day, to outside observers, everything seems perfectly normal. The Queen goes to mass as normal. She goes and has her hair done, very important for her. She goes out for a drive around the city in a coach with her children. And then that evening, she has dinner with her family,
王室从巴黎逃亡的尝试一切准备就绪。进展如何？正如我们所说，日期定在6月20日星期一。在那一天，对于外部观察者来说，一切似乎都非常正常。王后像往常一样去参加弥撒。她去做了头发，这对她来说非常重要。她带着孩子们坐马车去城里兜风。那天晚上，她和家人共进晚餐，
and that includes the king's brother, the Comte de Provence, and his sister, Madame Elizabeth. And then when dinner is over, or so it seems, she retires for the night. But there have been three odd little signs that day. First of all, the children's attendants had been sent away on the grounds that the children were ill, but they weren't ill. The children themselves noticed this and thought this was peculiar. Number two, if you'd been to the palace, to the Tuileries Gardens that day, you would have noticed an empty hackney cab, a fiacre as they're called
其中包括国王的弟弟普罗旺斯伯爵和他的妹妹伊丽莎白夫人。晚餐结束后，或者看起来是这样，她就回房休息了。但那天有三个奇怪的小迹象。首先，孩子们的侍从被支开了，理由是孩子们病了，但他们并没有生病。孩子们自己注意到了这一点，觉得很奇怪。第二，如果你那天去过宫殿，去过杜伊勒里花园，你会注意到一辆空的出租马车，也就是他们所说的 fiacre，
in French, sitting there at the Champs-Élysées. Nobody in it, nobody really notices it, but there it sits. And there's another empty cab just across the River Seine on the other side of the Seine. Again, just parked by the side of the road, nobody there. Again, nobody really notices it. Now, while Marion Sarnet is having her hair done and all of that kind of stuff, Louis is putting the finishing touches to a letter. And this letter is a disaster for him politically. But of course, he doesn't know that at the time. He writes it himself. It's in his own handwriting. And it is a note explaining why he intends to flee the capital. He just pours everything out. It's a list of his grievances, justifications for himself. He said, I'm not being kidnapped. No one's making me go. I'm going my own accord because for two years I've sat here and I've seen, and I quote, the destruction of the monarchy, the subversion of all authority, the violation of properties, the endangerment of personal security, crime left unpunished and the establishment of a complete anarchy. And he says, everything I've done in
法语里叫 fiacre，停在香榭丽舍大街上。里面没人，没人真正注意到它，但它就停在那里。塞纳河对岸还有另一辆空马车。同样，只是停在路边，没人。同样，没人真正注意到它。现在，当玛丽·安托瓦内特在做头发之类的琐事时，路易正在给一封信做最后的润色。这封信在政治上对他来说是一场灾难。但当然，他当时并不知道。是他亲手写的。是他自己的笔迹。这是一张解释他为什么要逃离首都的便条。他只是倾诉了一切。这是一份他的不满清单，为自己辩护。他说，我不是被绑架的。没有人强迫我走。我是自愿离开的，因为两年来我坐在这里，我看到了，引用他的话，“君主制的毁灭，所有权威的颠覆，财产的侵犯，人身安全的威胁，犯罪未受惩罚，以及彻底无政府状态的建立。”他说，我所做的一切
these two years, my captivity, I didn't mean any of it. You forced it out of me. I did only under duress. I've had enough of living a lie. I hate you. I hate the revolution. I'm out of here. That's his letter. Now you could say that's an admirably frank political testament. Or you could say it's mad. You could say this is a political suicide note. I mean, it leaves him no place to hide should the escape attempt go wrong. Yeah, he's burning all his bridges. Of course, he doesn't think that it might go wrong. Now, we can retrace what happens next in some detail because there's a brilliant book
这两年，我的囚禁，我不是真心的。是你们强迫我的。我只是在胁迫下才这么做的。我受够了活在谎言中。我恨你们。我恨这场革命。我要离开这里。这就是他的信。你可以说这是一份令人钦佩的坦率的政治遗嘱。或者你可以说它是疯狂的。你可以说这是一封政治自杀信。我的意思是，如果逃亡尝试失败，他将无处藏身。是的，他正在破釜沉舟。当然，他不认为这可能会失败。现在，我们可以详细回顾接下来发生的事情，因为有一本出色的书，
by the American historian Timothy Tackett called When the King Took Flight. So a lot of general histories are a little bit sketchy about the details, but he basically does it minute by minute. So when dinner was finished that evening, Louis embraced his brother, the Comte de Provence, and said, I'll see you at the frontier because the Comte de Provence is going to go on his own to Brussels, escape to Brussels. And that works, doesn't it? Yeah. The Com Count of Provence in due time
由美国历史学家蒂莫西·塔克特所著，书名是《国王出逃时》。所以很多通史对细节有点粗略，但他基本上是逐分钟还原的。所以那天晚上晚餐结束后，路易拥抱了他的弟弟普罗旺斯伯爵，并说，我在边境等你，因为普罗旺斯伯爵要独自前往布鲁塞尔，逃往布鲁塞尔。这成功了，不是吗？是的。普罗旺斯伯爵在适当的时候
will become Louis XVIII he will indeed so he gets away and this is by the way it's the last time those two brothers will ever see each other
将成为路易十八。他确实会。所以他逃脱了，顺便说一句，这是那两兄弟最后一次见面。
and then Marie Antoinette and her friend the Marquise de Torzel who's going to come with her who's been very loyal stuck by Marie Antoinette when others have left her
然后玛丽·安托瓦内特和她的朋友托泽尔侯爵夫人，她要和她一起走，她非常忠诚，在别人离开玛丽·安托瓦内特时，她一直陪伴着她。
yeah so a lot of her friends a lot of her favourites a lot of her favourites, a lot of the sort of petit trianons set have fled, haven't they? But she's stuck with her. She's the sort of best friend. They slip away from the dining room and they go to wake the two children and to get their nannies. Marie Antoinette, who's really leading the way in this,
是的，所以她的很多朋友，她的很多宠臣，很多小特里亚农宫圈子里的人都逃走了，不是吗？但她一直和她在一起。她是那种最好的朋友。她们从餐厅溜出来，去叫醒两个孩子，找他们的保姆。玛丽·安托瓦内特，她真的是这次行动的领导者，
she's planned this with Axel von Fersen. It's her scheme as much as anybody's. They go down these back stairs to the ground floor. There are disguises waiting there, and the nannies help the children change into the disguises. They're both going to be dressed as young girls. We'll explain in due course about the disguise plan. But then the nannies go back upstairs,
她和阿克塞尔·冯·费森一起策划了这件事。这和任何人的计划一样，都是她的主意。她们沿着后楼梯下到一楼。那里有伪装等着，保姆们帮孩子们换上伪装。他们俩都要打扮成小女孩。我们稍后会解释伪装计划。但随后保姆们回到楼上，
and it's the nannies. The nannies can easily come and go from the palace. They walk out of the main entrance, and they are heading across the river to the cab across the river so that was for them meanwhile back in the palace marion to an etters for their various subterfuges she's managed to get a key to an outer door she gets the children and she unlocks the outer door that she's timed this perfectly she's waited for the point when most of the palace servants will leave. Now, of course, it's June. So we're at the lightest time in the year.
是保姆们。保姆们可以很容易地进出宫殿。她们从正门走出去，正前往河对岸的马车，所以那是为她们准备的。与此同时，在宫殿里，玛丽·安托瓦内特为了各种掩护手段，她设法弄到了一把外门的钥匙，她带着孩子们，打开了外门，她算准了时间，她等到了大多数宫廷仆人离开的时候。现在，当然是六月。所以我们处于一年中天色最亮的时候。
But even so, after 1030, darkness has fallen. So the courtyard is lit by torches. The servants are all leaving. And as they are leaving, the door opens quietly. And the Marquis de Torsel and the two children slip out into the crowd and the guards don't notice them among the mass of servants. And so they then head to the cab and Dominic, who is driving the cab? So they get to the cab outside in the Tuileries Gardens and it is Axel von Fersen in his disguise. And this is why he'd be so good at solving crimes, isn't it?
但即便如此，10点半以后，天色已经暗了下来。所以庭院里点着火把。仆人们都在离开。当他们离开时，门悄悄打开了。托泽尔侯爵夫人和两个孩子溜进了人群，守卫们在成群的仆人中没有注意到他们。于是他们前往马车，多米尼克，是谁在驾驶马车？他们到达了杜伊勒里花园外面的马车，是伪装后的阿克塞尔·冯·费森。这就是为什么他如此擅长破案，不是吗？
He is such a tremendous man, Tom. The Marquis and the two kids get into the cab and then he says, you know, let's go for a little drive. And they go off because he's killing time waiting for the royal couple. He goes off for a little drive around the city. And he's kind of bantering away, isn't he? Yeah, and when
他真是个了不起的人，汤姆。侯爵夫人和两个孩子上了马车，然后他说，你知道，我们去兜兜风吧。他们就出发了，因为他在消磨时间等待王室夫妇。他开车在城里兜了一圈。他还在开玩笑，不是吗？是的，当
he comes back, he puts on the voice of a Parisian coachman. He exchanges banter with the other coachman. He stops and has a smoke with the other coachman and he's whistling and humming a tune. He's really behaving splendidly. I mean, everything that would make him, as you say, a brilliant detective. Brilliant. He's a tremendous man. Now the next person out is meant to be the king. And I mean, the whole story is so Hollywood. He's about to go when suddenly General Lafayette and Jean-Sylvain Bailly, the mayor of Paris, arrive to talk to him about a minor political issue. I mean, so late at night, who would have imagined it? And he has to stop and chat to them and answer their questions and say yes i'll do this or whatever whatever all very sort of perfunctory stuff and so that's basically an hour isn't it
他回来时，他装出巴黎马车夫的声音。他和其他马车夫开玩笑。他停下来和其他马车夫抽烟，他吹着口哨，哼着曲子。他表现得真是太棒了。我的意思是，正如你所说，所有这些都会让他成为一名出色的侦探。太棒了。他是个了不起的人。下一个出来的人应该是国王。我的意思是，整个故事太好莱坞了。他正要走，突然拉法耶特将军和巴黎市长让-西尔万·巴伊赶到，要和他谈一个小的政治问题。我的意思是，这么晚了，谁能想到呢？他不得不停下来和他们聊天，回答他们的问题，说好的我会做这个之类的，所有这些非常敷衍的事情，所以这基本上花了一个小时，不是吗？
yes and that means that you're an hour closer to dawn yeah so right from this point actually they're running late like nothing quite goes of course it's the nature of these things nothing quite goes according to plan so they leave at about 11 30 he then has to pretend to go to bed he dismisses his servants then he gets back out of bed he puts on his disguise which is a very plain kind of coat and hat and he goes out and he goes out this outer door across the courtyard i mean to be fair to louis he is so calm and cool under pressure he gets gets halfway across the courtyard, under the eyes of the guards. Then he stops, bends down and fiddles with the buckle of his shoe.
是的，这意味着你离黎明又近了一个小时。是的，所以从这一点开始，他们实际上已经迟到了，就像没有什么事情完全按照计划进行一样。所以他们在11点30分左右离开，他然后不得不假装去睡觉，他打发走了仆人，然后他从床上起来，穿上他的伪装，那是一种非常朴素的外套和帽子，他走了出去，他从外门穿过庭院，说句公道话，路易在压力下非常冷静和镇定，他走到庭院中间，在守卫的注视下。然后他停下来，弯下腰，摆弄鞋扣。
And of course, this does not look like a man escaping, right? This looks like a man who's just very relaxed. Quite impressive that he knows how to buckle his own shoe. Yeah. I'm sure he was like Churchill with a boiling of the eight.
当然，这看起来不像是一个逃跑的人，对吧？这看起来像是一个非常放松的人。他知道如何扣自己的鞋扣，这令人印象深刻。是的。我敢肯定他就像丘吉尔一样。
He's seen it done. Yeah, he's seen it done. So then he crosses the courtyard to Axel von Fursten's cab. And the last person to leave is Marion Twinette herself. And as she's out, she goes round a corner
他见过别人这样做。是的，他见过。所以他穿过庭院来到阿克塞尔·冯·费森的马车前。最后离开的是玛丽·安托瓦内特本人。当她出来时，她绕过一个拐角，
and she virtually bumps into Lafayette, who is leaving the palace. Oh God, fancy meeting you here. But it's in the torchlight. There's darkness. He doesn't recognise her. And she sort of shrinks back into the shadows for a second and then continues. So it's about 12 30 they're all in the cab they're about now as you
她几乎撞上了正在离开宫殿的拉法耶特。哦，天哪，真巧在这里遇见你。但在火把的光线下。天很黑。他没认出她。她缩回阴影里一秒钟，然后继续前进。所以大约12点30分，他们都上了马车，正如你
said behind schedule already axel von furson sets off and he drives very slowly and carefully through the streets of darkened streets of paris all the way to the gate of samaritan the edge of the city that's where he has parked this luxury vehicle, the Berlin Discrete. And now there's a little bit of a faff because he can't find the Berlin in the darkness because the Berlin is with these three guys who are the bodyguards. Finally, they meet up. They've lost another bit of time now. They basically parked their first cab in a ditch and they all transfer into the Berlin.
所说，已经落后于计划了。阿克塞尔·冯·费森出发了，他非常缓慢而小心地穿过巴黎黑暗的街道，一直开到城市边缘的圣马丁门。他在那里停放了那辆豪华车辆，柏林马车。现在有点麻烦，因为他在黑暗中找不到那辆柏林马车，因为柏林马车和那三个保镖在一起。最后，他们汇合了。他们现在又浪费了一些时间。他们基本上把第一辆马车扔进了沟里，然后全部换乘到柏林马车上。
They are now two hours behind schedule. However, they're at the edge of Paris. They've done well. They get in and Fersen says, go, go, go. It's going to get light very soon. And off they go east, heading out of the city into the countryside. The way they've planned this is that there will be relays of horses. That's the nature of any long-distance journey in France in the late 18th century. One set of horses won That's the nature of any long distance journey in France in the late 18th
他们现在比计划晚了两个小时。然而，他们已经在巴黎边缘了。他们做得很好。他们上了车，费森说，走，走，走。天很快就要亮了。他们向东出发，驶出城市进入乡村。他们计划的方式是会有马匹接力。这是18世纪末法国任何长途旅行的本质。一组马不会
century. One set of horses won't carry the whole way and they've planned the relay stops intricately. The first relay stop, a place called Bondy, Axel van Fersen splits up with them. He has handled this superbly so far. He is now going to go off on horseback, rather like the Comte de Provence, he's going to head into Belgium, to the Austrian Netherlands, and then he will meet them again when they finally get to the border at Montmedy. So it's emotional farewells, and then off he rides. The next stop at a place called Clay, they meet the cab with the two nannies in it. So now there's two of them traveling basically in convoy, and the party is complete, and they are heading east through the Ile de France towards Champagne.
走完全程，他们精心计划了接力站。第一个接力站，一个叫邦迪的地方，阿克塞尔·冯·费森与他们分开了。到目前为止，他处理得非常出色。他现在要骑马离开，就像普罗旺斯伯爵一样，他要前往比利时，前往奥属尼德兰，然后当他们最终到达蒙梅迪边境时，他会再次与他们会合。所以这是感人的告别，然后他骑马离开了。下一站是一个叫克莱的地方，他们遇到了载着两个保姆的马车。所以现在他们基本上是两辆车组成车队在旅行，队伍完整了，他们正向东穿过法兰西岛前往香槟地区。
So they rattle east across these roads. This is a major highway. You know, it's not a tarmac road of the kind that we recognize. And just to reiterate, this carriage, I mean, is massively indiscreet. It is massively indiscreet. And it's painted like a wasp, basically. Yeah, it is. So, I mean, it's...
所以他们沿着这些道路向东颠簸。这是一条主要公路。你知道，它不是我们所认识的那种柏油路。再次重申，这辆马车，我的意思是，非常招摇。它非常招摇。而且它基本上被漆得像只黄蜂。是的，它是。所以，我的意思是，它……
Yeah, black and yellow. Agreed. It's sort of kind of Hab a wasp, basically. Yeah, it is. So, I mean, it's... Yeah, black and yellow. Agreed. It's sort of kind of Habsburg colours, actually. But, you know, so far, so good. And the hours go by. Dawn breaks over the fields of Champagne. They're changing the horses at the relays as planned. You know, they're beginning to think...
是的，黑色和黄色。同意。它有点像哈布斯堡王朝的颜色，实际上。但是，你知道，到目前为止，一切顺利。时间流逝。黎明在香槟地区的田野上破晓。他们按照计划在接力站换马。你知道，他们开始认为……
We could do this. We could do this. The king, Louis, remember with him, his fascination with his looks. Louis is basically a bit of a nerd. do this we could do this the king louis remember with him his fascination with his looks louis is basically a bit of a nerd and louis has brought with him maps and he's brought a very detailed itinerary i love this about louis i admire this kind of baby this is what i would have done and he's got this itinerary and when they go through each village he says this is such and such a place and he's maybe got a few nice facts about it and he can kind of plot it on his map
我们可以做到。我们可以做到。国王，路易，记住他，他对自己的外表很着迷。路易基本上有点书呆子气，路易随身带着地图，他还带了一份非常详细的行程表。我喜欢路易的这一点，我钦佩这种……这就是我会做的事情，他有这份行程表，当他们经过每个村庄时，他说这是某某地方，他可能对它有一些好的了解，他可以把它标在地图上。
so really he's a frustrated tour guide he totally is he's loving this he's a travel agent yeah he's loving all this now while he's doing this the queen marion to net says to everybody now listen remember our parts madame the tourzel she's playing somebody called the baroness de corfe the two children are her two daughters marion to annette and the king's sister elizabeth are her two servants. Marie Antoinette and the king's sister Elizabeth are her two servants. And Louis, dressed in his kind of plain brown coat, is her business agent, is the baroness's business agent. Monsieur Durand. Exactly, Monsieur Durand. So if anybody asks who we are, that's who we are. Yeah. But again, it is, I mean, just to reiterate, there's a kind of slight sense in which it's symbolic rather than actual, isn't it?
所以他实际上是一个受挫的导游。他完全是，他很喜欢这样，他是个旅行社代理人，是的，他很喜欢这一切。现在，当他这样做时，王后玛丽·安托瓦内特对大家说，现在听着，记住我们的角色。托泽尔侯爵夫人，她扮演一个叫科尔夫男爵夫人的人，两个孩子是她的两个女儿，玛丽·安托瓦内特和国王的妹妹伊丽莎白是她的两个仆人。而路易，穿着他那种朴素的棕色外套，是她的商业代理人，是男爵夫人的商业代理人。杜朗先生。没错，杜朗先生。所以如果有人问我们是谁，那就是我们。是的。但同样，我的意思是，再次重申，这在某种程度上是象征性的，而不是实际的，不是吗？
This attempt to be a common person. Yeah, well, as we will see. Because actually, Louis, as they get out, the further they get from Paris, Louis becomes more and more relaxed. Understandably, he's out of the Tuileries for the first time in ages. And he just feels such a sense of liberation. He says to the others, when I'm back in the saddle, when everything is normal again, I will be such a different man. You won't recognize me. I'll be so different. You know, I will do such things. Exactly.
这种试图成为普通人的尝试。是的，正如我们将看到的。因为实际上，路易，当他们离开时，他们离巴黎越远，路易就变得越放松。可以理解，他很久以来第一次离开杜伊勒里宫。他感到一种解放感。他对其他人说，当我回到马背上，当一切恢复正常时，我将成为一个完全不同的人。你不会认出我的。我会变得如此不同。你知道，我会做那样的事情。没错。
Oh, the tragedy of it, Tom. The day breaks. It's a warm day. It's June in the center of France. They take off their hats. They look out of the windows. They watch the peasants working in the fields as they pass. Charming.
哦，汤姆，这真是个悲剧。天亮了。这是一个温暖的日子。这是六月的法国中部。他们摘下帽子。他们向窗外望去。他们看着农民在田里劳作。迷人。
So charming. And then when they stop every time to change the horses or to go to the loo or whatever, Louis starts to get out of the cab and he does a bit of an Axel von Fersen. He starts to chat to the people changing the horses. He says, lovely weather. How are the crops this year? I'm a land agent.
太迷人了。然后当他们每次停下来换马或去洗手间之类的时，路易开始下车，他开始模仿阿克塞尔·冯·费森。他开始和换马的人聊天。他说，天气真好。今年的庄稼怎么样？我是个土地代理人。
Yes. The bodyguards are sitting on the top, and they are attracting a lot of attention because they are wearing yellow uniforms that match the frame of the carriage. the chief émigré counter-revolutionary leader, is a guy called the Prince de Condé, the Prince of Condé, who is one of the exiles who is most feared in all the conspiracy theories. And his men wear yellow, and these guys are wearing yellow, so people are staring at them.
是的。保镖坐在车顶上，他们吸引了很多注意，因为他们穿着与马车框架相配的黄色制服。主要的流亡反革命领袖，是一个叫孔代亲王的人，孔代亲王，他是所有阴谋论中最令人恐惧的流亡者之一。他的人穿黄色，而这些人穿着黄色，所以人们盯着他们看。
And the bodyguards say to the king, people are staring at us, you know, we should be a bit more careful, a bit more discreet. This is, I think, a really important thing. Louis says, stop worrying. You know, we capital now in the countryside. We don't need to worry about all this. It's very Tsar Nicholas II or even Charles I or something. The city people are weirdos and have been polluted by the woke mind virus. But in the country, he says,
保镖对国王说，人们在盯着我们看，你知道，我们应该更小心一点，更谨慎一点。我认为这是一件非常重要的事情。路易说，别担心。你知道，我们现在在乡村。我们不需要担心这一切。这非常像沙皇尼古拉二世，甚至查理一世之类的。城里人是怪胎，被觉醒思想病毒污染了。但在乡下，他说，
La France Profonde, people actually love me. So it's fine even if I am recognized. And the thing is, he is being recognized. This is again, something that I think some of the sort of briefer accounts skip over. They say, he's spotted later on. He's already being spotted. So in Mont Montmeray a wagon driver spotted him when they were changing the horses in the place called Chantrix there was a postmaster who had seen him at the Bastille Day celebrations in 1790 and then as the day wears on they get to the biggest town they're going to cross which is a place called Chalon they get there mid-afternoon there will be a lot of people in this town by the nature of the town who will probably have seen them at Versailles. There will be notables and things like that. And by this
法兰西深处，人们实际上爱我。所以即使我被认出来也没关系。问题是，他正在被认出来。这又是，我认为一些简短的叙述跳过的事情。他们说，他后来被发现了。他其实早就被发现了。所以在蒙梅迪，当他们换马时，一个马车夫认出了他；在一个叫尚特里克斯的地方，有一个邮政局长在1790年的巴士底日庆典上见过他；然后随着时间的推移，他们到达了他们要经过的最大城镇，一个叫沙隆的地方，他们下午到达那里，这个城镇里会有很多人，他们可能在凡尔赛见过他们。会有名流之类的。到了
point, because they've been gone so long, Louis is incredibly relaxed. He doesn't take any precautions at all. I mean, it's just mad. And not least because back in Paris by now, people will have realised that they've gone, presumably. Of course, they realised first thing that morning when the servants went in and found their rooms empty. So it just seems mad behaviour. I mean, he could be hiding up an oak tree and instead he's kind of roaming around pretending to be a land agent. Mad. But he's got away with it so far, Tom.
这一点，因为他们离开太久了，路易变得非常放松。他根本没有采取任何预防措施。我的意思是，这简直是疯了。尤其是因为此时在巴黎，人们想必已经意识到他们走了。当然，那天早上仆人进去发现房间空了时，他们就意识到了。所以这看起来简直是疯狂的行为。我的意思是，他本可以躲在橡树上，但他却在到处游荡，假装自己是个土地代理人。疯了。但他到目前为止还没事，汤姆。
He hasn't though. We'll find out. Because nobody stops him in Chalon. People recognise him and people are whispering to each other and small crowds forming, but nobody stops them. They keep going as evening approaches. They're approaching the Argonne Forest and the borders of Lorraine. And they are very confident now that they have basically pulled this off because they've gone a long way. Because Lorraine is the home of Marie Antoinette's father, of course. Yeah, of course. And of course, on the eastern edge of France. So they're not that far away now. They are now three hours behind schedule,
他其实没没事。我们会发现的。因为在沙隆没人拦住他。人们认出了他，人们在窃窃私语，小群人聚集起来，但没人拦住他们。随着傍晚临近，他们继续前进。他们正在接近阿贡森林和洛林边境。他们现在非常有信心，因为他们已经走得很远了，他们基本上成功了。因为洛林当然是玛丽·安托瓦内特父亲的家乡。是的，当然。而且当然，在法国东部边缘。所以他们现在离得不远了。他们现在比计划晚了三个小时，
but they're confident that very soon they will rendezvous with a military escort that has been sent to wait for them under the duke de choiseul and as they approach the argonne forest they get to the place where they think they're going to meet this guy and he is nowhere to be seen and actually what has happened is this the duke de choiseul had arrived with a small group of cavalry but But wherever cavalry go in France in 1791, peasants are very alarmed because the peasants, of course, because of the revolution, have not paid their feudal dues, their seigneurial dues.
但他们相信很快就会与一支军事护卫队会合，这支护卫队是在舒瓦瑟尔公爵的指挥下被派来等他们的。当他们接近阿贡森林时，他们到达了他们认为会见到这个人的地方，但他不见踪影。实际上发生的事情是这样的：舒瓦瑟尔公爵带着一小队骑兵到达了，但是无论骑兵在1791年的法国去哪里，农民们都非常惊慌，因为农民们，当然，因为革命，没有支付他们的封建税，他们的领主税。
Yeah, so that was the grand peur, the great fear. The great fear, exactly. And when men and horses, armed men on horseback arrive, the peasants panic and think they're about to be punished or that these men have been sent to steal their crops or to take their money or something so schweizel is actually and his men attract a lot of attention angry crowds and people sort of throwing stones at them and shouting at them and stuff and by mid-afternoon because the king has fallen so far behind schedule schweiseul is sick of waiting or
是的，所以那是“大恐惧”。大恐惧，没错。当武装的骑兵到达时，农民们惊慌失措，认为他们要受到惩罚，或者这些人是被派来偷他们的庄稼，或者拿走他们的钱之类的。所以舒瓦瑟尔和他的手下吸引了很多注意，愤怒的人群，人们向他们扔石头，对他们大喊大叫。到了下午，因为国王比计划晚了太多，舒瓦瑟尔厌倦了等待，或者
is frightened and basically decides, he's probably not coming. This is awful. It's a very awkward and difficult situation. He's probably not coming. I'm actually just going to fall back to the nearest military encampment. And what is worse, he sends a message to other cavalry detachments in the area to say I actually don't think they're coming and who's the messenger
感到害怕，基本上决定，他可能不会来了。这太糟糕了。这是一个非常尴尬和困难的情况。他可能不会来了。我实际上要撤退到最近的军事营地。更糟糕的是，他给该地区的其他骑兵分遣队发了消息说，我真的认为他们不会来了，谁是信使？
Dominic well the messenger actually delivers the message very competently and the messenger Tom is the hairdresser Monsieur Leonard I love it
多米尼克，好吧，信使实际上非常称职地传达了消息，信使汤姆是理发师莱昂纳德先生。我喜欢这个。
I love the way he just keeps popping up and he does this very well and of course it's a disaster for Louis-Americk because Monsieur Leonard
我喜欢他不断出现的方式，他做得很好。当然，这对路易-安托瓦内特来说是一场灾难，因为莱昂纳德先生
goes around the area the the neighbourhood, riding or whatever to different cavalry groups and saying, the treasure's not arriving today. There will be new orders tomorrow. And this message. So Monsieur Léonard. And this message.
在附近地区到处跑，骑马或什么的，去不同的骑兵小组说，宝藏今天不会到了。明天会有新的命令。这条消息。所以莱昂纳德先生。这条消息。
Well, he's just doing what he'd been told to do. His mastery of codes. So with von Fersen's mastery of disguise and his mastery of codes. It's a brilliant team. They'd be an unbeatable combination. So darkness falls and the royal family have not met up with the escort that they hoped for. And they head on alone into the small town of Saint-Migneux,
好吧，他只是在做他被告知要做的事。他对密码的掌握。所以有了冯·费森对伪装的掌握和他对密码的掌握。这是一个出色的团队。他们将是一个不可战胜的组合。所以夜幕降临，王室没有遇到他们希望的护卫队。他们独自前往圣默努小镇，
as it is called. And there they start to change the horses once again. The stable hands at the post station are changing the horses. And they've almost finished when the man who runs the post station, basically the postmaster, arrives from the fields where he has been working. His name is Jean-Baptiste Drouet. He's 28 years old and he used to be in the cavalry. He's a very ambitious, upwardly mobile, self-confident man. And he comes in and he sees his stable hands changing these horses. And he looks into this huge carriage to see who's there because he's naturally curious.
正如它所称的那样。在那里，他们再次开始换马。邮局的马夫正在换马。他们快要完成时，经营邮局的人，基本上是邮政局长，从他工作的田地里赶来。他的名字叫让-巴蒂斯特·德鲁埃。他28岁，曾经在骑兵队服役。他是一个非常有野心、积极向上、自信的人。他走进来，看到马夫在换马。他往这辆巨大的马车里看，想看看里面是谁，因为他天生好奇。
And the first person he sees, he recognizes her straight away. It's Marie Antoinette. And then he looks at the man sitting next to her. And he's this big, fat, heavyset man who he hasn't seen before. But he had seen Marie Antoinette at Versailles when he was a cavalryman. But he hasn't seen this man. But he recognizes the man because the man has the same face that is on the new inflationary paper money. It's Louis XVI. The horses are now finished to change, and before Drouet can do anything, the carriage
他看到的第一个人，他立刻认出了她。是玛丽·安托瓦内特。然后他看着坐在她旁边的男人。这是一个又大又胖、身材魁梧的男人，他以前没见过。但他曾在凡尔赛当骑兵时见过玛丽·安托瓦内特。但他没见过这个男人。但他认出了这个男人，因为这个男人的脸和新发行的通货膨胀纸币上的脸一样。是路易十六。马匹现在换好了，在德鲁埃能做任何事之前，马车
rattles away out of the yard. And he's just standing there, and he says to the people around him, that was the king and queen. I know that was the king and queen. And Saint-Ménieu is a small place. People start to gather. And Drouet says, there's no doubt in my mind, that's who they were. And the local bigwigs appear. And they're like, what are they doing? Now, in this world where the conspiracy theories have been circulating all this time, they immediately say, he's going to get a foreign army. That's what he's going to do. He's going to invade this country and attack our revolution, stop our revolution. They might not be wrong.
摇摇晃晃地离开了院子。他只是站在那里，对周围的人说，那是国王和王后。我知道那是国王和王后。圣默努是个小地方。人们开始聚集。德鲁埃说，我心里毫无疑问，那就是他们。当地的大人物出现了。他们说，他们在做什么？现在，在这个阴谋论一直流传的世界里，他们立刻说，他要去弄一支外国军队。这就是他要做的。他要入侵这个国家，攻击我们的革命，阻止我们的革命。他们可能没说错。
Well, they're right. Yeah, they're absolutely right. And the town bigwigs say, who's the fastest rider? It's Drouet, who had once been a cavalryman. They say, you would get your mate Jean Guillaume. You go after them. You must tell people in the next town and stop them. The next town is a town called Varennes. At 11 o'clock, the royal coach approaches Varennes.
好吧，他们是对的。是的，他们绝对是对的。镇上的大人物说，谁骑得最快？是德鲁埃，他曾经是骑兵。他们说，你带上你的伙伴让·纪尧姆。你去追他们。你必须告诉下一个城镇的人并拦住他们。下一个城镇叫瓦雷讷。11点，皇家马车接近瓦雷讷。
It is an hour and a half ahead of Drouet, so they have a bit of time to play with. Varennes is about 1,500 people in the Argonne forest. Don't forget, they don't have their escort. Now, they were expecting that the army would leave horses for them on the outskirts of Varennes, but of course, the message has leave horses for them on the outskirts of Varennes. But of course, the message has gone around. The treasure is not coming today. So those horses are nowhere to be seen. The royal bodyguards get down.
它比德鲁埃早一个半小时，所以他们还有一点时间。瓦雷讷在阿贡森林里，大约有1500人。别忘了，他们没有护卫队。现在，他们原本期望军队会在瓦雷讷郊外为他们留下马匹，但当然，消息已经传开了。宝藏今天不会来了。所以那些马根本不见踪影。皇家保镖下车。
They look for them. They even knock on a few doors. No joy, no horses. There's a lot of dithering and arguing because the people with the current horses don't want to go on. They don't want to push the horses beyond the limits of their endurance. They've been specifically told not to go past Varennes. So there's then a bit of an argument. The drivers don't want to keep going until they've had a rest, until they've fed the horses and all of this stuff. And while this argument is going on, by the side of the road, Drouet and Guillaume ride right past them without even noticing them towards Varennes. Finally, the bodyguards get back onto the coach.
他们寻找马匹。他们甚至敲了几扇门。没用，没有马。有很多犹豫和争论，因为有现有马匹的人不想继续前进了。他们不想把马推到极限。他们被明确告知不要经过瓦雷讷。所以发生了一点争论。车夫不想在休息、喂马之前继续前进。当这场争论发生时，在路边，德鲁埃和纪尧姆骑马从他们身边经过，甚至没注意到他们，直接朝瓦雷讷去了。最后，保镖回到马车上。
They agree they'll go into Varennes and they'll see what they can do. And the carriages roll into Varennes, which is in total darkness now. We're virtually midnight. And then as they approach this inn in the centre of the town, the inn of the Golden Arm, they can hear people shouting voices. Somebody's shouting, fire, fire, which is the typical, the classic thing you shout to attract attention with any kind of emergency. And Madame de Torzel said later, she said,
他们同意进入瓦雷讷，看看能做什么。马车驶入瓦雷讷，那里现在一片漆黑。几乎是午夜了。然后当他们接近镇中心的一家旅馆，金臂旅馆时，他们能听到人们喊叫的声音。有人在喊，火，火，这是吸引注意力的典型方式。托泽尔夫人后来回忆说，
when we heard people shouting that, we thought we'd been betrayed. We drove down the street with a feeling of sadness and distress that can scarcely be described. And as they get to the Golden Arm, there are men standing there who stop the carriages and they think, oh no, oh no. So what had actually happened was that Drury had got there before them. He'd burst into the inn and he had said, the king and queen are coming for the sake of the country, for the sake of the revolution. They must be stopped. People aroused the local councillors, the local national guard, and the chief magistrate, who was a grocer with the excellent name of Jean-Baptiste Sauce, or as he would now call himself, Sauce.
当我们听到人们那样喊时，我们以为我们被出卖了。我们带着难以形容的悲伤和痛苦驱车穿过街道。当他们到达金臂旅馆时，那里站着拦住马车的人，他们想，哦不，哦不。所以实际上发生的事情是德鲁埃比他们先到。他冲进旅馆说，国王和王后来了，为了国家，为了革命。必须拦住他们。人们唤醒了当地议员、当地国民自卫军和首席治安官，他是一个杂货商，名字叫让-巴蒂斯特·索斯，或者正如他现在自称的那样，索斯。
They're the people who are standing outside the inn when the carriages arrive. You can picture the scene. People holding torches aloft in the darkness. They ask for their papers. They hand over the papers in the name of Baroness de Corfin. And actually, Sauce and the others say that these papers seem perfectly in order. Maybe we should let them go on. They're kind of muttering while Louis and Marion are waiting in terror in the carriage.
当马车到达时，他们就是站在旅馆外的人。你可以想象那个场景。人们在黑暗中举着火把。他们要求看证件。他们以科尔夫男爵夫人的名义交出了证件。实际上，索斯和其他人说这些证件看起来完全没问题。也许我们应该让他们走。当路易和玛丽在马车里惊恐地等待时，他们还在嘀咕。
And Drouet says, I swear this is the king and queen. You can't let them go. You absolutely can't let them go. So the bigwigs of the town, the town fathers say to themselves, why don't we just play for time and wait till the morning? So they say to the travellers, we just play for time or wait till the morning so they say to the travelers look it's very late we'll need more time to check your documents we'll do it in the morning also the road is very dangerous at night you'd be better off going in the morning anyway why don't you stay here Jean-Baptiste says do you know what you can stay in my house above
德鲁埃说，我发誓这就是国王和王后。你们不能让他们走。你们绝对不能让他们走。所以镇上的大人物，镇上的元老们对自己说，为什么我们不拖延时间等到早上呢？所以他们对旅行者说，我们拖延时间等到早上，所以他们对旅行者说，看，太晚了，我们需要更多时间检查你们的文件，我们明天早上再做。而且路边晚上很危险，无论如何你们最好早上走。为什么不留在这里？让-巴蒂斯特说，你知道吗，你们可以住在我的房子里，在
the grocer's shop I've got a bedroom for you and And very, very reluctantly, they get down from the carriage and they go to the grocer's house. And the two children, who are, of course, exhausted, are put to bed and then they wait. While Soce is leaving them there, he says, there's a bloke in the town, actually, who's seen the king and queen, a judge, because he married a woman from Versailles, Monsieur Destes.
杂货店楼上。我有一间卧室给你们。他们非常、非常不情愿地从马车上下来，去了杂货商的家。两个孩子，当然已经精疲力竭，被送上床睡觉，然后他们等待。当索斯把他们留在那里时，他说，镇上其实有一个人见过国王和王后，一个法官，因为他娶了一个凡尔赛的女人，德斯特先生。
I'll go and get him. He goes and wakes him up, bangs on his door, brings him to his house. This guy, Destes, comes up the stairs, goes into the bedroom. As soon as he sees Louis XVI, he drops to his knees and he says, oh, your highness, your majesty. And Louis stands up and he says, yes, I am your king. I have come to live among you, my faithful children. I will never abandon you. And then he does this incredible thing. Timothy Tackett says, he took the members of the municipal council in his arms one by one and embraced them.
我去把他找来。他去叫醒他，敲他的门，把他带到家里。这个叫德斯特的人走上楼梯，走进卧室。他一看到路易十六，就跪下说，哦，殿下，陛下。路易站起来说，是的，我是你们的国王。我来这里是为了生活在你们中间，我忠诚的孩子们。我永远不会抛弃你们。然后他做了这件不可思议的事。蒂莫西·塔克特说，他把市政委员会的成员一个接一个地抱在怀里，拥抱了他们。
And he told them his story. He said, I've been living in the capital surrounded by daggers and bayonets, but I've come to the countryside to seek the freedom and tranquility that you all enjoy. It's a very Rousseau. Yeah, totally. But he's basically saying, please help me. My life and the lives of my family are in danger. He's framing it in a way that is with the grain of kind of revolutionary sentiment. I mean, that's the extraordinary feat. I mean, not bad, actually, in the context of the absolute meltdown of all his plans. Well, do you know what? It almost works because they are dumbstruck that the king, I mean, he's in the upstairs
他告诉了他们他的故事。他说，我一直生活在首都，被匕首和刺刀包围，但我来到乡下是为了寻求你们所有人享有的自由和宁静。这非常卢梭。是的，完全是。但他基本上是在说，请帮帮我。我和我家人的生命处于危险之中。他以一种符合革命情绪的方式来表达。我的意思是，这是一项非凡的壮举。我的意思是，在所有计划彻底崩溃的情况下，这还不算太坏。好吧，你知道吗？它几乎成功了，因为他们被国王惊呆了，我的意思是，他在楼上。
bedroom of a grocer's house. It's an inconceivable that, I mean, 1789, this would have been beyond the realms of the wildest fantasy that this would happen. They're shaking with nerves and fear and emotion to be in the presence of the wildest fantasy that this would happen. They're shaking with nerves and fear and emotion to be in the presence of the king. And they say they will help him. For a moment, they say, of course, of course, if necessary, we will accompany you east ourselves, if that's what it takes. Then they all go downstairs. And it's actually while they're going downstairs that they're like, actually, maybe we shouldn't do this. And Timothy Tackett,
杂货店老板的卧室。这简直不可思议，我是说，在1789年，这简直是天方夜谭，根本不可能发生。他们因为身处国王面前而紧张、恐惧、激动得浑身发抖。他们说会帮助他。片刻之后，他们说，当然，当然，如果有必要，如果非要这样不可，我们会亲自陪您向东走。然后他们都下楼了。实际上，就在他们下楼的时候，他们开始想，其实，也许我们不该这么做。而蒂莫西·塔克特（Timothy Tackett），
who I mentioned already, his book is brilliant on this. He says, you have to look at Varenne itself, what had happened in Varenne to make sense of this. Varenne is a completely nondescript, ordinary town. But in towns like Varennes, there had been a degree of politicisation that had never been before since the revolution began. They have sent delegates to the National Assembly. They've had meetings. They have their own little Jacobin club in Varennes that all the bigwigs belong to.
我之前提到过他，他关于此事的书写得非常精彩。他说，你必须看看瓦雷讷（Varennes）本身，看看瓦雷讷发生了什么，才能理解这一切。瓦雷讷是一个完全不起眼的普通小镇。但在像瓦雷讷这样的城镇里，自革命开始以来，政治化程度达到了前所未有的水平。他们向国民议会派遣了代表。他们举行了会议。他们在瓦雷讷有自己的小雅各宾俱乐部，所有的大人物都是成员。
And also, for two years, they have been subject to the, what you talked about, Tom, le grand peur, the great fear. Fears of brigands and foreign armies. Particularly being close to the frontier. Yeah. You know, they would be in the front line of any invasion coming. Exactly. And so they say, actually, now this is a terrible situation.
而且，两年来，他们一直受到你所说的“大恐慌”（la grande peur）的影响。对强盗和外国军队的恐惧。特别是由于靠近边境。是的。你知道，他们会处于任何入侵的第一线。没错。所以他们说，实际上，现在情况非常糟糕。
Like, maybe he's raising a foreign army. And they start to panic. And they say, finally, ring the tocsin, ring the bells, call the alarm. Now, this is a terrible situation. And suddenly it's one o'clock in the morning and the church bells are tolling the tocsin. People are banging on drums, shouting, fire, fire, alarm, alarm. People are pouring into the streets. They run to the town hall to get guns. And people are sending messages to the local villages, to arms, to arms. Everything's kicking off.
比如，也许他正在组建一支外国军队。他们开始恐慌。他们说，最后，敲响警钟，敲响钟声，发出警报。现在，情况非常糟糕。突然间，凌晨一点，教堂的钟声敲响了警报。人们敲着鼓，大喊着，着火了，着火了，警报，警报。人们涌向街头。他们跑到市政厅去拿枪。人们向当地村庄发送消息，拿起武器，拿起武器。一切都乱套了。
And of course, Louis and Marin Tonnet would be upstairs in that room listening to all this and just realizing that it's all going horrendously wrong. So if we just fast forward a few hours, by dawn, the street outside the grocery is absolutely rammed with people. Militia bands, basically. People with pikes and with sticks and with battered old muskets and all this kind of thing louis and marion today have not slept a wink they're in terrible state the kids have been asleep i guess but about daybreak sauce and the other bigwigs come back to louis and they say um actually we've changed our mind we can't let you go on they say we're like members of a great family who've just found their father, but we fear we may lose him again. And they say, you know, everybody loves you. You're in everybody's hearts, but your place is in Paris,
当然，路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特在楼上的房间里听着这一切，意识到一切都变得极其糟糕。如果我们快进几个小时，到黎明时分，杂货店外的街道上挤满了人。基本上是民兵。人们拿着长矛、棍棒和破旧的火枪之类的东西。路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特一宿没睡，状态极差。我想孩子们睡着了，但大约天亮时，索斯（Sauce）和其他大人物回到路易身边，他们说，嗯，其实我们改变主意了，我们不能让你继续前行。他们说，我们就像一个大家庭的成员，刚刚找到了父亲，但我们担心可能会再次失去他。他们说，你知道，每个人都爱你。你在每个人的心中，但你的位置在巴黎，
and we want you to go back to Paris. And Louis and Marie Antoinette, you can just picture the scene. They're desperately arguing with them. Please let us go. We'll die in Paris. And then at 6 o'clock in the morning, two men arrive from Paris and they're couriers with a message from General Lafayette. The morning of the 21st, when the news had broken that the palace was deserted, Lafayette and the National Assembly had sent messages all over France,
我们希望你回到巴黎。路易和玛丽·安托瓦内特，你可以想象当时的场景。他们拼命地与他们争论。请让我们走吧。我们在巴黎会死的。然后在早上6点，两个从巴黎来的人到了，他们是拉法耶特将军的信使，带着信息。21日早晨，当宫殿空无一人的消息传出时，拉法耶特和国民议会向法国各地发送了信息，
stop them, intercept them, do not let them get away. And they hand these messages, these decrees, the couriers to the royal family. Marion Toinette just spits out. She says, what insolence? And she throws the message to the ground. But a very revealing little sign of their two characters. Louis doesn't react. He's not angry. He's just tired and sad.
阻止他们，拦截他们，不要让他们逃脱。他们把这些信息、这些法令交给了王室。玛丽·安托瓦内特只是啐了一口。她说，多么傲慢？她把信息扔在地上。但这显示了他们两人性格的一个非常明显的特征。路易没有反应。他不生气。他只是疲惫和悲伤。
And he says, there's no longer a king in France. So at 7.30, they're led downstairs and they're put back into these carriages. Huge crowds standing around. This is worse than when they were brought from Versailles to Paris. Oh, totally. Because they've failed. The October thing in 1789 was humiliating.
他说，法国不再有国王了。所以在7点半，他们被带下楼，重新放回马车里。周围站着巨大的人群。这比他们从凡尔赛被带到巴黎时还要糟糕。哦，完全是。因为他们失败了。1789年10月的那件事是羞辱性的。
But this is, they're guilty. They've been caught. That's the thing. They come down, the crowds all pressing around them, people staring at them, all this, and people start to shout, Vive la nation! Go back to Paris! And all this stuff. But not Vive le Roi.
但这次，他们有罪。他们被抓住了。这就是重点。他们下来时，人群挤在他们周围，人们盯着他们，所有这些，人们开始高喊，法兰西万岁！回巴黎去！诸如此类。但不是“国王万岁”。
Not Vive le Roi. The journey west, they then head west again with this huge crowd surrounding them. It's a four-day journey this time. It's very tiring. It's very hot, incredibly dusty, because the great weight of the people surrounding them brings up loads of dust from these kind of roads and all the old kind of abusive canards that have
不是“国王万岁”。向西的旅程，他们再次向西前进，周围是巨大的人群。这次是四天的旅程。非常累人。非常热，尘土飞扬，因为包围他们的大量人群从这些道路上扬起了大量的灰尘，所有那些古老的辱骂性的谣言又
been aimed at both marie antoinette and louis are kind of wheeled out again aren't they so marie antoinette is this voracious vampire sexually predatory yeah been sleeping around everyone and louis is the kind of feeble cookhold and their characters are now absolutely being set in that kind of abusive cast totally they are i mean if you think about they're in this carriage this kind of airless horrible environment day after day at least they've got their chamber pots exactly and the picnic equipment and they are um surrounded by thousands of people who as as you say, are shouting abuse through the windows, throwing stones.
被拿出来针对玛丽·安托瓦内特和路易了，不是吗？所以玛丽·安托瓦内特是一个贪婪的吸血鬼，性掠夺者，是的，和每个人睡觉，而路易是一个软弱的戴绿帽子的丈夫，他们的性格现在完全被定格在那种辱骂性的刻板印象中，完全是这样。我是说，如果你想想，他们每天都待在这辆马车里，这种空气不流通、可怕的环境中。至少他们有便壶，没错，还有野餐设备，他们被成千上万的人包围着，正如你所说，这些人对着窗户大喊大叫，扔石头。
And the royal bodyguards, the three nobles in the yellow coats, are still sitting on the top. And people are hurling earth at them and dung and all this kind of thing. Dead cats, exactly. So it's a really horrible scene. There is actually one moment of violence. So outside Saint-Domingue, a local nobleman,
而王室保镖，那三个穿着黄色外套的贵族，仍然坐在车顶上。人们向他们投掷泥土、粪便之类的东西。死猫，没错。所以这是一个非常可怕的场景。实际上有一个暴力时刻。在圣德尼（Saint-Domingue）外，一位当地贵族，
a young count called dompierre tries to ride up to the carriage to shout long live the king you know he's wants to show his solidarity with them the crowd drive him off and he rides off into the fields louis is watching all this in the windows his own peasants pursue him they shoot him drag him off his horse and then stab him to death with their kind of knives and pitchforks and stuff. So that must have helped set Louis' nerves. It sets my to rest. On the second day, they were joined by three men from the National Assembly.
一位名叫唐皮埃尔（Dompierre）的年轻伯爵试图骑马靠近马车，高喊国王万岁，你知道，他想表达对他们的支持，人群把他赶走了，他骑马逃向田野。路易在窗户里看着这一切，他自己的农民追赶他，他们开枪打中他，把他从马上拖下来，然后用刀和干草叉之类的东西把他刺死。所以这一定有助于让路易感到紧张。这让我感到不安。第二天，国民议会派来的三个人加入了他们。
The National Assembly agreed they would send three people of different ideological persuasions to ride back with them. A monarchist, a radical, and this guy, Barnab, that we mentioned, the guy from Grenoble, who's the kind of big man in the National Assembly, and he sits next to Marie Antoinette. And will have quite the relationship with her in due course. Yeah, he's got a slight, it's not really a crush, but basically they talk a lot as the carriage rolls west. And he starts to think, she and I, we understand each other, we can do business together. And as we will see for Barnab and his faction, who end up being called the Foyon, this is a very bad miscalculation. Because obviously, it reminds actually the ground is shifting so quickly that even the person who now seems to have the kind of political upper hand doesn't realize. Yesterday's radical is today's centrist.
国民议会同意派遣三个持不同意识形态的人与他们一起返回。一个保皇党，一个激进派，还有我们提到的那个来自格勒诺布尔的巴纳夫（Barnave），他是国民议会里的大人物，他坐在玛丽·安托瓦内特旁边。以后他和她会有相当多的交集。是的，他有一点，不是真的迷恋，但基本上他们在马车向西行驶时谈了很多。他开始想，她和我，我们互相理解，我们可以一起做生意。正如我们将看到的，对于巴纳夫和他的派系（后来被称为斐扬派）来说，这是一个非常糟糕的误判。因为显然，这提醒人们，局势变化得如此之快，以至于即使是现在似乎占据政治上风的人也没有意识到。昨天的激进派就是今天的中间派。
Exactly. Well, that's exactly it. Finally, they approach the Paris suburbs and the mood now is very aggressive. There are attempts to storm the carriage, which the National Guardsmen have to kind of fight off. The scuffling between the National Guard escort and the crowds, which leave people wounded. And finally, they get into the city walls. They're surrounded by Lafayette's cavalry and the carriage comes into the city. All Paris has turned out to watch tens of thousands of people people crammed into balconies they're on trees and they're packed into the pavements and it's just a total silence no
没错。嗯，就是这样。最后，他们接近巴黎郊区，现在的气氛非常具有攻击性。有人试图冲击马车，国民警卫队不得不击退他们。国民警卫队护送人员和人群之间的扭打导致人员受伤。最后，他们进入了城墙。他们被拉法耶特的骑兵包围，马车进入了城市。整个巴黎都出来观看，成千上万的人挤在阳台上，他们在树上，挤在人行道上，一片死寂，没有
shouting they've been told they've been ordered you know no noise from the the orders that come down from the authorities the hats remain stubbornly on their heads they don't remove their hats when the royal carriage passes it's an atmosphere that actually it's not just silent it is terrifying as the carriage comes along and at last they reach the Tuileries palace the guards are all crowding around them to protect them Louis and Marion Ternet and the children are able to get down and to walk inside but when the bodyguards three noblemen get down in their yellow coats the crowd break through the cordon they basically rip into the bodyguards and start to kind of tear them apart lafayette's men have to kind of push back to intervene and
叫喊声，他们被告知，他们被命令，你知道，当局下达的命令是不准发出噪音。帽子顽固地戴在头上，当皇家马车经过时，他们没有摘下帽子。这种气氛实际上不仅是沉默，而且是可怕的，当马车经过时。最后他们到达了杜伊勒里宫，卫兵们挤在他们周围保护他们。路易、玛丽·安托瓦内特和孩子们得以走下车，走进里面。但当那三个穿着黄色外套的贵族保镖下车时，人群冲破了警戒线，他们基本上冲向保镖，开始把他们撕碎。拉法耶特的人不得不推开人群进行干预，
basically drag away the battered blooded bodyguards to safety and then the gates of the tuileries clanged shut and the doors slammed shut by marion twinett and louis they're back home again and it's over they failed and of course what's worse he'd left that note and everybody has read it and it is patently clear that he will never work you know deep down he will never reconcile himself to the revolution and that he has been lying all along so don't just before we end this episode and the series with it i guess one obvious question could it have worked could louis have got away yeah i think he could have worked you know a lot of contingencies go wrong they fall behind schedule he's recognized you know if he'd been more careful and if they'd kept to the plan, of course, you can argue that they would always have fallen behind and that by definition, he was always going to be a bit indiscreet. But the thing is, it doesn't fail by accident. There is a lot of accident, but it's not just accident. So there are two reasons I think that are crucial why it fails. One is his indecision plays a massive part in the story of the French Revolution,
基本上把伤痕累累、血迹斑斑的保镖拖到安全地带，然后杜伊勒里宫的大门砰地关上，玛丽·安托瓦内特和路易关上了门。他们又回家了，一切都结束了。他们失败了。当然，更糟糕的是，他留下了那张字条，每个人都读过了，很明显他永远不会工作，你知道，在内心深处，他永远不会与革命和解，他一直都在撒谎。所以，在我们结束这一集和整个系列之前，我想一个明显的问题是，这本可以成功吗？路易能逃脱吗？是的，我认为这本可以成功，你知道，很多偶然事件出了问题，他们落后于计划，他被认出来了，你知道，如果他更小心，如果他们坚持计划，当然，你可以争辩说他们总是会落后，而且根据定义，他总是会有点轻率。但问题是，它不是偶然失败的。有很多偶然因素，但不仅仅是偶然。所以我认为有两个原因至关重要，为什么它失败了。一个是他的优柔寡断在法国大革命的故事中扮演了重要角色，
but it also plays a big part in this story because if he had gone in 1789, when all his advisors were begging him to go, at least some of them, the chances of success would have been much higher. Even in 1790, they'd have been much higher. But by delaying and delaying, he makes it more likely that it fails. And why? This is the other thing, because La France Profonde, the countryside, has changed in ways that he doesn't ever anticipate. Even in two years.
但它在这个故事中也扮演了重要角色，因为如果他在1789年就走了，当时他所有的顾问都在恳求他走，至少其中一些人，成功的机会会高得多。即使在1790年，机会也会高得多。但通过不断的拖延，他使失败的可能性变得更大。为什么？这是另一件事，因为“法兰西深处”（La France Profonde），即乡村，已经以他从未预料到的方式发生了变化。即使在两年内。
So he thought it was all, it's the classic thing, isn't it? It's Nicholas II in St. Petersburg. It's Charles I in London. Oh, it's just the people in the city. The other people love me, which is what Louis thought. He didn't realize that even a tiny, nothing place like Varennes had changed completely and that actually when push came to shove, they would stick with the National Assembly and their own elected deputies rather than with him.
所以他以为这一切，这是经典的情况，不是吗？就像圣彼得堡的尼古拉二世，伦敦的查理一世。哦，这只是城市里的人。其他人爱我，这就是路易所想的。他没有意识到，即使像瓦雷讷这样微不足道的地方也已经完全改变了，实际上当关键时刻到来时，他们会坚持支持国民议会和他们自己选出的代表，而不是他。
So in a way, it's not just chance that stops him. It's the revolution that stops him because the revolution has changed everything. And the revolution in due course now will destroy him and the royal family and the monarchy. And the course is now clearly set for France to become a republic. But that is a story for another time. Probably in the autumn, we will continue this account of the revolution. But thank you for sticking with us this far. We will be back.
所以从某种意义上说，不仅仅是运气阻止了他。是革命阻止了他，因为革命改变了一切。而革命在适当的时候现在将摧毁他和王室以及君主制。法国成为共和国的道路现在已经明确设定了。但那是另一个时间的故事。可能在秋天，我们将继续讲述这场革命。但感谢你们一直坚持到这里。我们会回来的。
Dominic, I've enjoyed doing this so much. One of the great, great convulsive episodes in world history, as we've been saying, and lots more convulsions still to come. Yeah, we'll be back in the autumn with the fall of the monarchy, the outbreak of war. Guillotine.
多米尼克，我非常享受做这件事。正如我们所说，这是世界历史上最伟大的痉挛性事件之一，还有更多的痉挛即将到来。是的，我们将在秋天回来，讲述君主制的垮台、战争的爆发。断头台。
The guillotine. And the beginning of the reign of terror. Murder of Mar. Guillotine. The guillotine and the beginning of the reign of terror. Murder of Marat. Yeah. So much to come. Brilliant stuff. And our next episode will be something completely different, namely the faking of a prehistoric skull in early 20th century Sussex.
断头台。以及恐怖统治的开始。马拉之死。断头台。断头台和恐怖统治的开始。马拉之死。是的。还有很多事情要发生。精彩的内容。我们的下一集将完全不同，即20世纪初苏塞克斯郡伪造史前头骨的故事。
We'll be looking at the Piltdown Man. And then after that, we'll be looking at the history of Italian food. So a slight palate cleanser there. Definitely a palate cleanser. So we will see you soon. A bientot. Au revoir. I'm Marina Hyde.
我们将看看皮尔特道恩人（Piltdown Man）。然后在那之后，我们将看看意大利食物的历史。所以那里有一个小小的味觉清洁剂。绝对是一个味觉清洁剂。所以我们很快就会再见。再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《剩下的就是娱乐》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点点演艺圈八卦，在我们的问答环节，我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和提前获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。